you say you are morally obligated to do
remarkable things
why well I think partly because life is
so difficult and challenging that unless
you give it everything you have the
chances are very high that it will
embitter you and then you'll be a force
for darkness and not good and
so you know the the fact that life is
short and can be brutal can terrify you
into
hiding and avoiding but it it can also
you can flip that on its head and
understand that since you're all in
anyways you might as well take take the
risks that are
adventurous and that's a very good thing
to
understand and what is also useful to
understand in that manner is that there
isn't anything more adventurous than the
truth this is something that took me a
long time to figure out well you can
craft your words to get what you want
you know and people do that all the time
they craft their words so they can avoid
taking responsibility for things they
should take responsibility for they can
craft their words to gain an advantage
that they really don't deserve that's
what you do when you
manipulate and the problem with that you
might say well why not do that if I can
get what I want and the answer that is
you aren't necessarily the best judge of
what you need and it's easy to be
diluted in what you want and that's the
sort of delusions that people chase if
they chase
power if you decide instead that you're
going to just say what you believe to be
true you have to let go of the
consequences and you might think well I
don't want to let go of the consequences
because I want to control what's going
on but what you miss then is Adventure
because if you don't control what's
going on you don't know what the hell's
going to happen and maybe that's
exciting and actually there's no doubt
about it and then you have the
additional Advantage if you're
attempting to say what you believe to be
true and attempting to act in the manner
that you think is most appropriate
that's genuinely you and you have the
force of reality behind you and
obviously that's what you have if you're
trying to say live in the truth is you
have the force of reality behind you
that seems like a good deal then you
have the reality and the adventure so
why is that a moral obligation well if
you hide and you don't let what's inside
of you out and you don't bring into the
world what you could bring and you
become cynical and bitter you will start
doing very dark things so you'll start
in not only will you not add to the
world what you could add but you'll
start being jealous of people who are
competent and doing well and work to
destroy them
so that's the pathway to hell
really so one of the trends that I've
been railing against most recently has
been cynicism is this pervasive belief
that everything is terrible and it can't
get better and the people who believe
that it can improve a dumb and
delusional and the problem
and I I don't know where it comes from I
don't I don't well it's the beginning of
wisdom cynicism this is part of the
reason why it's hard to combat
you know because people start out naive
and naive people are optimistic but not
really they're just naive and naive
people have no idea that there's say
malevolence in the world they have no
idea that there's malevolence in their
own heart they're sheltered and
dependent and when that breaks it often
breaks into cynicism and so cynicism is
actually an improvement the veils have
fallen from your eyes exactly exactly
the problem with cynicism is that
especially if it's allied with a kind of
arrogance is that you can end there and
that's a big mistake so then the
question becomes what once you once
you've been bitten hard and you're no
longer naive well that is very hard on
your optimism let's say so then the
question is how do you restore that
without reverting to the naivity which
you can't do anyways without blinding
yourself once you've been bitten and the
answer to that is you substitute courage
for naivity and you and you regain your
optimism as a moral imperative right so
one of the things you might ask yourself
is well if the future is likely to be
catastrophic in a variety of different
ways which is definitely the case both
socially and personally then what
attitude should you bring to bear on
that and the answer might be well if you
were courageous and faithful and I can
explain what that means then you would
conduct yourself in in a manner that met
the future headon with with the
presumption that you can manage it and
this is the presumption we should bring
to bear politically now
these the people who are using fear to
Garner
power point to the various apocalypses
that might befall us and it's difficult
to counter them because the future is
always an apocalyptic Horizon like
everything can fall apart and and has
before and might well again and will in
fact in your life as you age die and so
it's very easy to conjure up an
apocalypse then the question becomes the
question becomes not is that apocalypse
potentially real because the answer to
that is yes but what attitude should you
have towards that naive that's not good
cynical that's that's better but it's
still not good it's another form of hell
and it also tends to make the potential
apocalypses more likely well so what do
you have when you move Beyond cynicism
and what you have when you move Beyond
cynicism is wisdom and that's not naive
it's Courageous one of the things that
religious people have done relatively
badly especially in recent years is they
failed to delineate the relationship
between faith and courage you know
people like Dawkins and the new atheists
they point to Faith and they describe it
as something like belief in foolish
superstitions but that isn't really what
faith in the deepest sense means it
means that you are willing to act out
the proposition that you can ride the
wave no matter how big it becomes and
that we can all do that together
especially if we do that in Good Will
and I think that's that's a much more
it's a much more appropriate way to
confront the future and it's also the
proper medication for cynicism now the
other thing the cynics see the other
thing about cynicism that's interesting
too is that cynics aren't cynical enough
about their own cynicism right because
you can get doubtful enough to start
doubting the validity of your own
cynicism it's like what makes you so
smart what makes you the judge of being
you know the Coline kids were like that
you know they decided that existence
itself was unsustainable given its
cruelty and that the proper response was
to put up a giant middle finger to man
men and God right
well here's a way of being cynical about
cynicism how does your cynicism let you
off the hook right how does your
cynicism justify your desire to avoid
necessary responsibility and to pursue
your own short-term hedonic gains it's
like why aren't you cynical about your
own doubt and that's that's another
place where wisdom begins it's like that
so that's two
right cynicism beats naivity but it's
not the ultimate destination and you
should be cynical enough to question the
moral validity of your own of your own
resentment and your own what would you
say your own turning away from the world
the way that I see it given that we
don't know the future given that much of
our motivations are invisible to us
we're not a Crystal Pond that we can see
into you have to have some form of
delusion about what's going to happen in
the future you're trying your best to
see the way that it's going to be but
given that the glass could be half empty
or half full why not have a delusion
that's going to be useful to you one of
Hope even in the face and the
understanding that things might be
difficult and that there's going to be
obstacles yeah there was a there was a
line of social psychology that pursued
that argument for quite a while that
made the argument that people had to
have positive Illusions about the future
and that that was the fundamental way
that people staved off Despair and
bolstered their self-esteem but I don't
think I don't
think we need to separate out the
distinction between fantasy and delusion
you do have a fantasy about the future
you have to because like you said it's
not structured so you have to you have
to provisionally map the future that's
what a plan is a strategy is right but
that doesn't make it a delusion like it
becomes a delusion when the map Bears no
relationship to the underlying territory
so if you have a strategy for the future
you know maybe let's say that your
strategy for the future just for the
sake of argument is that you have 5
million YouTube subscribers in three
years
well you have no
evidence of the strict sort that that's
how it's going to be because Anything
could happen between now and 3 years
from now let's say
but
you there's no reason to call that a
delusion it's a it's one it's one
hypothetically possible path of
potential and then you can make the
sacrifices necessary to bring that about
so even though it's a fantasy because
map something that isn't there it's not
a delusion it's a delusion when you're
ignoring elements of your own experience
that would inform your fantasy more
effectively you're ignoring them so that
you can live in a positive
representation of the future without
having to pay the appropriate price for
it one of my favorite ideas I learned
over the last couple of years is the
inner Citadel from Isaiah Belin do you
know this m so Isaiah Belin says when
the natural roads toward human
fulfillment is blocked human beings
Retreat into themselves become involved
in themselves and try to create inwardly
that world which some evil Fate has
denied them externally that's a delusion
often if you cannot obtain from the
world that which you really desire you
must teach yourself not to want it if
you cannot get what you want you must
teach yourself to want what you can get
this is a very frequent form of
spiritual retreat in depth into a kind
of inner Citadel in which you lock
yourself up against all of the fearful
ills of the world Mutual Rob Henderson
explained it in a simpler way if your
leg is wounded you can try to treat the
leg M and if you can't then you cut the
leg off and announce that the desire for
legs is misguided and must be subdued
and I think that we see this everywhere
well okay so you so imagine that you lay
out a plan and it meets with an
impediment and it knocks the slots out
from underneath the plan okay now you
Retreat okay now you have an option when
you're retreating and one option is to
construct a world in fantasy where
you're taking revenge on those who
wronged you and getting what you want
that's that's a pathway to Madness so
often people who develop serious
delusions do develop um what would you
call them their their compensatory
fantasies and then they start to dwell
in them and often for hundreds of hours
so the the kids again who shed up the
Coline high school they dwelt in a
fantasy world for hundreds of hours
before they undertook their Dreadful
actions right but you can also flip flip
back into yourself let's say and you can
this is like this is like confession and
atonement it's a proper way to think
about it is you can think about what it
is that you did wrong or insufficiently
that led to the collapse of your plan
right so that's the first investigation
I made some sacrifices I attempted to
bring about a particular form of the
future it didn't happen okay why well
the world is set against me and the
cosmos is evil and there's no God and
I'm bitter and cynical that's one
potential explanation right poor me
right and and I'm not trying to be
flippant about this because sometimes
people's dreams are quite realistic and
they still fail catastrophically you
know it can be brutal you know maybe you
did make a lot of good decisions and you
suddenly got ill or someone in your
family did and everything went to hell
on you it doesn't have to be because
you've done something cardinally foolish
that you fail you know it's built into
the structure of the world but it
doesn't matter you can also Retreat into
to yourself and you can say something
like all right I need to retool my
conception of strategy but also
potentially my conception of goal you
know maybe I'm looking in the wrong
place maybe I have to look somewhere
else and you can open yourself up to a
revelation so there's a gospel statement
that's very relevant to this so Christ
tells his followers that if they knock
the door will open if they ask they'll
receive and if they seek they'll find
and so it sounds like it sounds magical
it sounds sounds like the sort of thing
that the new atheists would have a field
day with but that isn't that's not an
wise interpretation of that saying the
proper interpretation is something more
like a recognition of the way thought
works so imagine your plans didn't work
out okay now you sit down and you say to
yourself I'd like to
know even if the world was conspiring
against me and my failure was 95 % the
fault of external occurrences and other
people what did I do that wasn't as good
as it could have been and where did I
fail to look so that the probability of
my failure was higher now now to ask
that question you have to want the
answer that's that's what it means to
knock or to ask or to seek this this is
no joke it's like you have to want to
know and it's a very painful thing to do
because especially if you had given it
you're all to the degree you are
able and you have reason to be
bitter you're going to be searching for
the errors that you still made and
discovering your own errors is always
extremely painful right especially if
they're errors that you're in love with
and so you have to be willing to strip
yourself down that's what humility means
fundamentally and then but the advantage
is this is why it's so useful to listen
to people you might find out where
you're
stupid and then you could stop being
stupid and so one of the reasons you
confess your sins let's say is because
you want to discover where you're
insufficient now it's painful you know
it's painful to encounter an impediment
in the form of someone else's opinion
that might show you where you're blind
and ignorant or willfully blind even but
the advantage to that is you can rectify
the error and then as you move forward
you're stronger you know one of the
things I taught my kids and I hope Le at
least somewhat successfully was
that you should always ask a stupid
question and and that doesn't mean the
sort of question that someone who wasn't
paying attention would
ask if you're listening to
someone and you don't understand what
they're saying and you reveal that
you're revealing your ignorance you know
and maybe you're in a room full of
people and you think you're the only
person stupid enough to not get it which
is very rarely the case by the way the
thing is though if you if you reveal
that ignorance to yourself and to the
other person they can Rectify it and if
you do that a thousand times you're not
ignorant anymore and and this is a real
Pathway to success too you see it you do
this because you ask real questions in
your podcast and Rogan does this okay
Rogan's always trying to be a little
smarter than he already is and then that
works iterated like if you ask a
thousand dumb questions and you listen
to the answer then you know a thousand
things some of them deep that you didn't
know before so that's the that's the ADV
anage to searching your soul let's say
for the for unrequited sins and
attempting to atone that's not a
delusion right it's an attempt to set
yourself right it's the opposite of a
delusion even though there can be a
Fantastical element to it yeah the uh
conversation around people who try their
best do as many things right as they
could and yet still fall short because
the world is random and and unfortunate
things happen happiness as far as I can
see it sits in the gap between your
expectations and
reality but the problem here is that
people who have high standards often end
up feeling a lack right how can people
who strive like this avoid feeling
despondent at falling short of their own
high standards I've heard you talk about
the Statue of David saying something
like you are not all that you could be
yeah and as soon as you posit an ideal
you begin to compare yourself to that
ideal so well part that's a good
question I mean um the ultimate ideal is
also the ultimate judge because the
ultimate ideal is is something against
which you fall far short and that might
be so painful that you can barely stand
it but then what you do is you you you
two things I suppose is you lower the
ideal and you raise your estimation of
your Poss of your potential and what do
I mean by lower the ideal well if you're
comparing yourself to someone or even to
a future self and the Gap is so painful
that it paralyzes you then you've
created a dragon that you don't have the
tools to master and so what you have to
do is you have to scale the dragon down
to size and you want to scale the dragon
down to size until it's a size that you
are willing to move toward however small
that is now you know if you're here your
ideal is here and that Gap is unbearable
then you reduce the Gap and you reduce
the Gap and you're going to have to do
that anyways because you're not going to
move from where you are to perfect in
one Fell Swoop right there's going to be
incremental steps so you have to fill in
that that hierarchy of
progression
with with a high enough resolution
representation so that you can start to
move forward and and then you should be
butress there's another gospel comment
that's very interesting it has to do
with it's called the Matthew principle
and the Matthew principle is to those
who have everything more will be given
and from those who have nothing
everything will be taken now it's brutal
because it implies that reality works
like this when you're moving up you go
like this right and that's pretty nice
that's a lot better than this but when
you're going down you go like that right
it's like downhill downhill Cliff okay
so you want to avoid the downhill path
well if the uphill path is like this
which is like exponential let's say or
geometric then what that means is
that it doesn't matter how big the first
steps you take uphill are even if
they're trivial even if they're shameful
in their in their size because you're so
useless that if you're if you're
disciplined in that you'll speed up
extraordinarily rapidly and so that's
the good news you might say is that you
can take very small steps even ones that
might be shameful in their size and you
have to admit that to yourself but once
you get the ball rolling it doesn't roll
in a linear fashion it rolls in a
geometric fashion and this is a really
good thing to know because it can take
the sting out of the realization of your
own stupidity it's like yeah you know
everybody has their weak sides let's say
things they're embarrassed about when I
first started going to the gym I was
like how old was I 1985 23 and I think I
weighed 135 lbs and I was F 6'1 very
very thin a TW I write 27 inch waist
something like that I smoked like mad
and I drank too much like I wasn't in
good shape the
first the first attempts forward I took
in the gym I went to this swim sze class
Jesus it was me and this like really fat
guy young guy probably not in any worse
shape than me and like seven old women
over 70 and they could outswim me like
it was pretty damn humiliating and so I
did a semester of that and got myself in
somewhat better shape and then I started
to go to the gym to work out to lift
weights and that was also rough because
you know I'd be underneath the bloody
bench press trying to lift 75 lounds off
the off the rests and you know some
muscle-headed bastard would come over
and tell me how to do it and it's like
yeah thank you but you know it's
embarrassing and lots of times people
won't do things like go to the gym
because they're so embarrassed about how
they look or what sort of shape they're
in and it's a pain to start at the
bottom
but you start at the bottom where you're
weak and if you want to rectify what's
weak you have to accept the fact that
you're at the bottom and that the first
steps are going to be painful you know I
it took me about 3 years but I stopped
smoking and then I stopped drinking and
I gained 40 pounds of muscle in like
three and a half years something like
that I basically had to stop doing that
cuz I had to eat like six times a day it
was crazy but I got a lot more
physically confident and a lot
more coordinated cuz working out with
dumbbells makes you coordinated right
because it it exercises all the small
ligaments and the tendons and so my
lower body in particular got a lot more
coordinated then I could dance so that
was better when I was going out dancing
because I did a lot of that in graduate
school and but the point of all this is
if you're going to rectify your
weaknesses you have to admit your
insufficiency to your own shame now if
the gap between you and your ideal is so
great that it paralyzes you you shrink
that right we'll get back to talking to
Jordan in one minute but first I need to
tell you about Maui Nei venison Maui Nei
venison is the most protein dense and
nutrient-dense red meat on the planet
thank you plus they're the only
stress-free 100% wild harvested meat
available
my favorite method for cooking it is
straight from Frozen salt the hell out
of both sides 12 minutes in an air fryer
at maximum temperature turn it over 12
minutes again and it is perfect every
single time it is such a life hack
actually taught to me by Jordan's
daughter Michaela and all she does is
eat meat so that's the way to do it all
of the cuts are spectacular but their
venison sticks have been my new favorite
while I've been traveling on the road
you can get the healthiest red meat on
the planet delivered directly to your
door by following the link in the show
notes below or or going to Maui venison
tocom wisdom using the code modern
wisdom at checkout that's 20% off by
going to M Nui venison docomo wisdom and
modern wisdom at
checkout one of the things I've been
talking about in the live shows is your
comparison group is incorrect the fact
that you know we have the opportunity to
sit down and listen to anybody on the
planet right the best Minds the best
athletes the best things thinkers the
most
articulate that are alive right now or
listen to the people that have died that
were around when video cameras existed
and you can compare yourself to that
group yeah but that's not your
comparison group if you have the impetus
to sit down and listen to me and you
waffle on for three hours about these
deep topics these interesting ideas you
are so already selected out of the
normal group mhm you're already asking
yourself questions that almost nobody
almost nobody else is right but because
your comparison group of people that are
unbelievably High performing I remember
before I started my podcast i' listen to
to you or to Sam or to Joe and I'd think
God their recall is is amazing it's so
it's like that they they've just got
this identic memory and everything that
they've ever read is able to come to the
surface and they're able to say it in
this way that's completely seamless and
all the rest of it we go okay well are
you really person that's never recorded
a podcast before going to compare
yourself to Joe Rogan man that's
recorded a thousand and spent 10,000
hours on stage and done all of this UFC
commentary and done all of this stuff in
terms of TV is that really who you're
going to compare yourself to and it's
unfair and the problem that I see is
people who have big dreams for
themselves and want to do great things
they like to set their sights High yeah
and yet they feel despondent In the
comparison so I think well there's a
pride in that too e like I can be I want
to be well or that's who I should be
comparing myself to right that's the
pride and the pride is something like I
should be that or even I could be that
it's like well maybe you could but
you're certainly not going to do it as
you already pointed out without the
apprenticeship right so you could say
that the despondency is actually is is
in proportion to the to the false Pride
now I wrote a chapter in I think my
first book which was compare yourself to
who you are today not to who someone
else is it's sorry I I mangled that to
some degree but you get the point the
proper comparison group for you is you
yesterday because you can make first of
all you're the you're your you're the
only control group that's appropriate to
you because you have a certain set of
talents and possibilities and
limitations and tragedies that are truly
unique to you and so you might be
comparing yourself to someone else on
some Dimension but it's not a reasonable
comparison because you don't know what
talents they were blessed with and you
also don't know what opportunities they
had that you didn't Etc it's just not a
reasonable comparison it's a lot better
to think about who you were and then to
think well could you be somewhat better
in some Dimension and the the positive
thing about that is the answer is almost
always yes now you can Orient that
transformation towards some Stellar
Target and that's a reasonable thing to
do
but that doesn't exactly mean that you
should compare yourself to that Target
aiming at something and comparing
yourself to it are not exactly the same
thing plus your bloody comparison is
also a delusion you know that's another
thing that you have to understand is
that you look at the person you're
jealous of and really what you're doing
is you're you're looking through a very
narrow aperture at a very thin slice of
their life you're looking at the thin
slice of their life that's turning out
the best but you're also looking at a
thin slice of their life that's marketed
to be the best right and you have no
idea what the horror of that person's
life might be in its totality and you
have no idea if like if the deal was say
you wanted to
be Russell Brand there's a good example
you want it to be Russell Brand you want
it to be as charismatic and as famous as
he is well you're
real wish is that you get to have
everything Russell Brand has but none of
his problems well come on I mean that's
just it's just it's no wonder that a
vision like that would make you
despondent because it's it's naive it's
resentful it's jealous it's bitter and
it's
unreasonable you have to take the good
with the bad you have to take the bad
with the good and people very rarely
think about that when they're thinking
about you know the famous people they
think they'd like to be there was a
recent interview with Elon Musk where he
said something my mind is a storm I
don't think most people would want to be
me right they may think they would want
to be me but they don't they don't know
they don't understand what do you think
of that elon's someone that people
probably look up to and admire and
aspire to be one of the downsides to
high level genius is you might describe
it as hyper
so here's a simple test that people can
do so this is a test of something called
verbal fluency and verbal fluency is
associated with creativity and so a ver
here's a simple verb verbal fluency test
write down as many four-letter words as
you can in three minutes that begin with
t okay that's that's pretty constrained
four letters in t or or write down as
many words as you can in 3 minutes to
begin with S that's less constrained all
right right so there's quite a powerful
correlation between the sheer number of
words that you produce and your lifetime
creative achievement right especially in
the artistic and verbal
domains that's different than vocabulary
vocabulary is how many words you
understand fluency is how many words you
can produce in a given Dey those yeah
well people vary to a degree that you
can hardly imagine so some people if you
get them to do the four-letter test in
three minutes they'll write down like 12
words and some will write down
150 and the ones who are writing down
150 their minds are going at a hypomanic
rate they're just thinking five times as
fast bing bing bing yeah without any
remission whatsoever and you know when
that gets completely out of control you
have manic you have someone who's Manic
and there's nothing fun about manic
that's where the word m IC comes from
and someone who manic has a thousand
different plans Each of which are one
sentence long that they're hyper
enthusiastic about they'll spend every
scent of their money pursuing them and
things just go immediately to hell and
so that's the that's the outer limit of
pathology on the creative front and
someone like musk who's clearly a genius
that's what he's contending with in his
internal landscape now I'm not saying
that he's manic because I see no signs
of that but someone that creative is on
that edge or you see someone like Ben
Shapiro I mean it's very interesting to
talk to Ben because and Russell Brand is
the same
way Shapiro speaks I think more rapidly
than anyone I ever met but if you're
with him you see very clearly that he's
probably thinking five times that fast
and that's a lot and when I was writing
maps of meaning which was my first book
I had a very difficult time shutting off
my mind I was obsessed with that book
and so I was writing about 3 hours a day
and then I was thinking about the
material
like for 12
hours as and the thoughts came
as way faster than thinking they
probably came about as fast as I can
read I can read about 12200 words a
minute if the material isn't
overwhelmingly dense and so it was just
nonstop thought for like 16 hours a day
that's part of the reason I started
lifting weights because if I was lifting
heavy enough think of 12200 words a
minute while I've got 100 pound on my
back it was enough to shut it down and
it was also one of the reasons that I
drank because that was another thing
that would shut it off yeah well I I
think the price that people pay to be
the person that you admire is just such
an interesting frame to look at someone
like Elon Musk my mind is a storm I
don't think most people would want to be
me the price that you would have to pay
in order to be me is not one that you
would but you one of the richest men on
the planet and you get to you know dance
on stage and and release cars
bulletproof and put rockets in space and
stuff well yeah but what about all of
the baggage what's the pr what's well
he's also he also appears to me to be
hyper conscientious and I know people
who've worked with him like musk isn't
just a creative genius he's also an
extremely conscientious engineer which
and really conscientious Engineers they
have very interesting Minds I like
talking to Engineers because my
brother-in-law is a great engineer and
when when he understands something Jim
when he understands something he
understands how to build it out of atoms
right like he understands it at every
single level and musk appears to me to
be someone who's this rare combination
of hyper creative but also hyper
conscientious I know works all the time
yeah does that sort of uh hypertrophied
executive function help to Wrangle some
of the diffuse Creative Energy or we're
going to put it into this one thing at
least for a while and then we'll move on
to another thing yes yes definitely
definit
you you Eric Weinstein's a good example
of someone I hope Eric isn't annoyed by
this but Eric is unbelievably creative
but he's not particularly conscientious
and so his and and I think he found an
occupation where that works extremely
well because he's he I don't know if
he's still doing this but he worked with
Peter teal for quite a long time as his
idea man right and Eric's an extremely
interesting person musk is hyper
creative and as far as I can tell hyper
conscientious and the conscientious ious
does Focus know it it and and that lots
of people who are creative aren't
conscientious well it's rare like if
you're one in the there's no correlation
between creativity and
conscientiousness okay so if you're one
in a thousand if you're the most
creative person in a thousand and you're
the most conscientious person in a
thousand you're one person in a million
and musk is probably more like one
person in a 100 million right something
like that maybe more but or maybe a
billion right
maybe yeah it's interesting to consider
the changes that happen to people as
well as they as that their platforms as
the scrutiny around them continues to
increase obviously this has been a
journey for you over the last you know
nearly approaching 10 years now of was
it 2006 was that pH c16 2016 2016 yeah
sorry
um how have you found Fame change you
what's been impacted or changed due to
the the scrutiny and the surveillance
and the Adoration and the
criticism well the first thing that
changed I think was that I saw misery on
a scale that I hadn't really seen it
before you know I had worked as a
clinician for a long time and i' worked
with say 20 people a week and I was
always in the realm of difficult
existential problems rest wrestling with
my clients problems alongside of them
and I liked that a lot and then I had my
research and I had my family and various
business interests and so that misery in
some ways was contained and boxed in and
I had a lot of structure around that to
be able to function despite the fact
that you know I was neck deep in 20
people's serious problems which I really
like by the way when when I started
speaking on a larger scale and meeting
more and more
people the scale of demoralization
really hit me I didn't know that I
didn't know how deep the demoralization
in our culture had become and I think
that was especially obvious to me at
that point among young men now it looks
like this is Jonathan Height's research
is indicating this that possibly young
women are even in worse shape but for
what ever reason most of the people I
was meeting at least to begin with were
young men I think it was probably
because most of them far more people on
YouTube are young men and so the it was
shocking and brutal to see how much
demoralization
how widely spread the demoralization in
our culture
was other than that and that that was a
real shock and it it was very hard on me
I would say
um everything else about it has been at
minimum ridiculously
interesting I have an unbelievable
wealth of opportunity I'd be a fool to
be anything but abjectly grateful I mean
the misery that I saw was a shock and it
hurt me and it it was part of what made
how did that how did that impact you did
it change the way that you see the world
at
all
it made me understand more deeply how
important it was to offer people an
encouraging
word I could see that so many people
were
dying psychologically or actually for
lack of an encouraging word and so it
made being in the position to provide
that much
more necessary I mean part of the reason
that Tammy and I too are
constantly is because it seems to be
good it seems to be a good thing you
know we've even seen changes in the
audience so five years ago six years ago
when we did our first tour a lot of the
people who came to the talks were in
pretty rough shape there were more men
than there are now like the proportion
of men to women was higher and the men
were generally there alone and they were
a lot of them were looking pretty ragged
around the edges and now five years
later half the audience comes in suits
like it's as if they're dressed for a
wedding most of the guys are there with
some woman um the the audience members
are doing much better and the lecture
events are extremely positive you know
if you looked at my life from the
outside you'd think that I was in a
constant storm of you know aggravated
controversy but all of that virtually
all of that is virtual
it's just in the online world now it
touches the actual World from time to
time because I am being pursued by my
regulatory College inario yeah yeah yeah
which is you know mostly just an
annoyance and a Preposterous annoyance a
Preposterous expensive and timec
consuming annoyance but apart from
that everything that's happened around
me has
been
positive that a strange thing too
positive at such an intensity that even
that is
daunting you know you'd
think it's hard to imagine that you
could be in a situation where things are
so positive that you can barely stand it
but but I am in that situation and it's
quite something to contend with I I was
fortunate I suppose to some degree that
it didn't happen to me till I was old
cuz I've never really I've never really
got accustomed to it I've had a thought
about this observing what's happened to
you and you know the Weinstein are a
good example of this too we often hear
the Perils of getting Fame too young the
McCauley Culkin of the world the Britney
Spears of the world you know uh
individuals who don't have any sense of
identity being thrust into a
non-representative experience of the
world and they're completely
unmowed but I think that there's an
equally interesting question to ask okay
and what happens if you think you know
who you are if you've spent decades five
decades six Decades of your life
understanding your place your status the
trajectory that you're on and then out
of nowhere you get ripped away from all
of the areas of reference all of the way
markers that you thought you knew and
now you're just floating in the air I
imagine that could be even more
disquieting in some ways
well when everything blew up around me
to begin with it was stressful I would
say because my job was on the line my
university job and I never thought that
would happen I
mean my when I worked at Harvard an at
the University of
Toronto that was all positive like I
really liked working with my graduate
students I had at least cordial
relationships with my with my fellow
faculty members at Harvard they were
more than cordial at the University of
Toronto most of the faculty members that
I started to develop friendships with
were also those who ended up moving away
and so and they were often people who
got offers from other places and you
know they they would disappear and so a
lot of the friends I developed at the
University of Toronto went elsewhere and
so I didn't get as tightly tied
in with regards to Friendship networks
among my peers as I had at Harvard for
example but I had great relationships
with undergraduates and with my graduate
students that was plenty like I loved
working with my graduate students and so
it wasn't like I was pining and alone
not at all and I had a good network of
friends and
um and so then that was threatened and
really disappeared in
2016 um and my clinical practice was
threatened and so that was
unsettling I think there were things
that continued though even when I was
teaching as a university Professor the
way I taught
wasn't
typical the things I taught weren't
typical I thought for decades you know
eventually someone's going to find out
what I'm teaching and and you know
there's going to be trouble I couldn't
believe I was allowed
encouraged to teach what I was teaching
um but you know the universities and
this was particularly true of Harvard in
the
90s that's how they were structured what
was so rebellious about what what you
were
teaching well there wasn't really
anybody who was concentrating on the
Nexus between say archetypal ideas
archetypal and religious ideas in
Neuroscience so that wasn't a thing I
mean there was a few people Yak PP was
one of them who a lot of the researchers
who were interested in the Neuroscience
of emotion became interested in deep
narrative because they started to
understand that our emotional life is a
story that's a good way of thinking
about it and that we're guided you know
we're Guided by our emotional instinct
and what our emotional instincts do is
put us into certain stories that's what
it means to be in love for example is
that you're in a love story and yeah
it's not it's not uh a particular
balance of oxytocin and endorphins that
you are aware of it's not broken down to
its constituent Parts no definitely not
part of a narrative that you tell
yourself about what this means and how
this feels right right well and it's
interesting that the Instinct manifests
itself as a story and so I was very
interested in narrative and story and I
and also see no psychologist study Carl
Yung like literally virtually none
really now oh yeah yeah no definitely
not I mean
psychology psychology really developed
in some ways as the materialist
antithesis to
psychoanalysis so Freud and Yung and
even Adler to some degree they were off
limits for
for scientifically trained behavioral
psychology ologists and that's what I
was and am like I trained at Migel there
were no courses in psychoanalytic theory
at Migel I read Freud and Yung
completely on my own uh flying in the
face of the advice that I was getting
even from my well-meaning graduate
supervisor who was a great guy and who
never got in my way in the least quite
the contrary but I was warned for
example when I went on the job market
not to talk about the things that I was
truly interested in and I ignored that
that by the way and what that meant was
some places that I went to apply for a
job didn't want me but then Harvard did
so that worked out quite nicely you know
and that's one of the advantages too
also of being true to your own vision is
that you won't get what you don't want
see I didn't want to go work somewhere
where they wouldn't want me I wanted to
go work somewhere where they wanted me
so my strategy was well this is who I am
and if you don't want me you know that's
a drag cuz I'm looking for a job but by
the same token I'm not going to pretend
to be someone other than who I am so I
can work here what a stupid way of
starting your career well that goes back
to the truth right telling the truth
what are you going to if you tell a
sufficiently seductive lie what is the
best that you can hope for right the
person that you're telling the lie to
falls in love with a projection right
right absolutely well when I applied to
graduate school I wrote a crazy
admissions letter and and I basically
laid out who I was flaws and all and
what I was interested in and two people
three people bit and the one that
I liked best partly because he was at
Mcgill and I wanted to be in Montreal
with my graduate supervisor Robert Peele
and he knew what he was getting and we
had a great time I still work with him
like I had one of the best relationships
with Bob that I've ever had with anyone
in my life and it's lasted four decades
and it was because like Bob's a very
honest person we were very different
he's very practical he's a very good
administrator managerial type although
he's he's super smart he had an
exhaustive knowledge of the relevant
research psychology literature and I
came in you know flying on a mat of
psychoanalytic theory and philosophy and
religious ideas very very different
although we shared a real deep interest
in the practicalities of research and he
taught me how to fall in love with the
more scientific end of the research
distribution but the point I'm making is
that he knew he knew what he was getting
right from the beginning and so did I
and that worked like a charm there was
no re reason for any sort of subterfuge
and it turned out that our his talents
and mine dovetailed extremely well so
and we had a blast I loved working with
well like that's why we've been working
together for 40 years I traveled over
over North America with Bob because we
also started a business and uh it was
great it was great the thing is you know
if you tell people who you are and an
opportunity opens up it opens up for you
yes not for this thing you've created
this LIE there's this story that Douglas
Murray told me about one of his first
bosses at an early newspaper that he
worked at I can't remember the
gentleman's
name this guy is a legend within the
industry he's been working for a long
time he's accumulated a number number of
uh haters and and fans and toward the
back end of his career as Douglas is
starting his he decides that he wants to
release a West End play about the life
of Prince Charles in rhyming
couplets adventurous as as West End
plays go and obviously there was all of
this scrutiny because he was this very
welln individual within the publishing
world and uh opening night by the
halftime interval there was no one left
in the entire Auditorium in including
the cast and this guy was devastated
right and he was mocked in the press and
all the rest of it apparently Douglas
saw him shortly afterward and asked him
kindly he like look like what were you
thinking West End play about the life of
Prince Charles and [__] rhyming
couplets he said well Douglas I followed
my instincts and instincts that may
sometimes Lead You Wrong mhm but they're
the only thing that's ever led you right
right right and that's stuck with with
me because yeah well well there there
there's something very relevant there
too on the instinctual front Okay so
things will beckon to you and call to
you and you'll have intuitions about
which pathway to take and you will in
all likelihood follow those because what
else do you have you have these
orienting
instincts this is another reason why you
don't
lie because if you lie and you practice
lying you pathologize your instinct
and then your intuitions lead you wrong
and so there's a sin that's laid out in
the gospels it's the sin against the
Holy Ghost and it's unforgivable and
people have been debating for like 2,000
years about what this particular sin is
but it's something
like the pathologization of the
instincts that Orient you if you
sacrifice your relationship to the truth
you warp your vision and then you can't
see and then one day it'll be dark and
they'll be Sharp things in the fog in
front of you and you'll wander right
into them because you've pathologized
your own Vision yeah you don't want to
lie because you you program yourself
falsely and then you automatically see
what isn't there and then of course the
world will slap you in the face
continually and you'll think oh my God
the world's such a pathological place
when the truth of the matter is is that
no you just keep running into things
that you refuse to see and then you
think well the world's made of nothing
but obstacles it's like well you put the
obstacles in your own path and you did
that by developing these complex
self-serving delusions a story that you
tell other people about who you are that
isn't true you're trying to lay out a
map that bears no relationship to
reality and you keep wondering why you
wander off the path and into a pit it's
like well how could it be otherwise if
see if you really un this people have
commented to me many times about my
bravery and I I I don't like that I it's
it's it's not
right I'm afraid of different things
than the typical person maybe that's a
good way of thinking about it I'm way
more afraid of the consequences of
saying something that's false or
wandering off the appropriate path than
I am of whatever consequences might come
for saying what I believe and doing what
I believe to be the case I'm way more
afraid of that you
know I've been reading the gospel of St
Matthew I'm I'm writing a book at the
moment called we who wrestle with God
and one of the things Christ says to
people continually is to not damage
their vision is to not
put that's the best way of putting it
don't olude your eye you can see what's
in front of you if you're willing to see
it and if if you're willing to see it
the terrible OB many of the terrible
obstacles in life you can just walk
around but if you blind yourself
purposefully to follow your own narrow
self-serving delusion you're going to
run into terrible things and terrible
people and the terrible part of your own
soul all the time that's what you should
be afraid of well the best thing that
you can hope for if you do do that is to
fluke success living somebody else's
life right right great wonderful yeah
exactly you get to be you get to be a
successful fraud I remember this
documentary about Ron Jeremy I think
they called him the Hedgehog he was this
famous porn star I've seen a music video
with him in yeah yeah okay not one of
the world's most attractive people
physically and you know he lived in this
very interesting world he lived in this
world he was stopped constantly on the
street by people who thought Ron Jeremy
was a
hero right so he was in hell
because the people who admired him were
the people who
admired he was surrounded by the people
who thought that he was an avatar of
success right and so he got what he
wanted I
suppose he had easy access to easy women
in other news this episode is brought to
you by manscaped if you are a gentleman
who is still using an old face shaver
from three Christmases ago to trim your
gentleman's area what are you doing join
us here in the modern world there are
purpose built tools for the job and the
brand new lawn mower 5.0 Ultra is the
tool that you need it's got a Cutting
Edge ceramic blade to reduce grooming
accidents a 90-minute battery so that
you can take a longer shave waterproof
technology so that you can groom in the
shower and an LED light which
illuminates grooming areas for a closer
and more precise trim or if you just
want to do it in the dark like a ninja
would going into the holiday season you
might want to get the man in your life a
gift or hint at him that he's a tiny bit
more hairy than you would like and the
manscaped lawn mower 5.0 Ultra is the
perfect blending of these two worlds
since we're on YouTube I can't show you
how this actually works but what I can
show you is that transformation right
there that's you gentlemen unwrap the
gift of smoothness this season by going
to the link in the description below or
heading to manscaped.com wisdom using
the code wisdom at checkout for 20% off
and free shipping that's manscape.com
wisdom and wisdom at checkout well let
me give you let me give you this this is
why I think the beginning of the incel
movement and the blackpill movement was
born out of pickip partistry the origin
if you trace it back using internet
history of the Insel blackpill uh
ideology was a I think it's a subreddit
or a website called Pua hate pickup
artist hate and what it was was a group
of men who had been through the pipeline
of pickup Artistry yeah and come out the
other side with a very jaded and even
more jaded view of the world even more
jaded yes and I'll tell you why so so
what happens if a guy learns old school
mid2 norts pickup Artistry m is you
realize that there is a particular set
of actions a script that you can run
which makes it more likely that a woman
is going to go to bed with you right
right right right but what you realize
when you do that as you learn how to neg
and do Kino escalation and tell them
that story about the [__] fight
outside or whatever your script is that
you're running you you then begin to see
just how far away that person is from
the person that you actually show up as
right who you are and this extravagant
Persona that you need to convolute into
existence in order to get this woman
into bed makes you feel worse
even feel the gap between where you are
and what you have to do in order to
achieve the thing that you want now what
you don't realize is that there are a
million other ways that you could become
sufficiently Charming to get this person
to like you this by actually doing it
for example this is just one that
happens to be robust and easy enough to
write down in a book and easy enough for
basically a form of scripted
psychopathy so what a psychopath does is
feain competence right so most
psychopaths are very emotionally stable
and so one of
the early stage markers for competence
is self-possession and calmness and so
if you're not an anxious person you've
got an edge on that already and most
psychopaths are very high in emotional
stability and so they look confident
because confident people tend not to be
that nervous like if you're doing
something you're expert at well you're
not nervous because you know how to do
it okay so the lack of nervousness is a
hint to competence well you can feain
that you can feain competence you can
feain confidence that's what the pickup
artists teach now I would say there
there's even some utility in what they
do right because if you're dependent and
bitter and resentful and charmless and
self
destructive and nervous and socially
unskilled the probability that you're
going to be successful with women is
very very low okay so you should be
other than who you are now if you start
putting on this Persona then you could
think about that as a new suit of
clothes and you could learn through that
how to fill in the gaps take it until
you make it absolutely absolutely but if
you take on that without doing the
effort necessary to integrate that in a
genuine way then all that's happening is
that you're you're being rewarded for
being fake yeah right and that's part of
the problem with that too is that you're
practicing learning how to manipulate
people in a psychopathic way and if you
practice that of course you're going to
become jaded like there's nothing more
jaded than a psychopath I mean that's
that's the ultimate extreme of jadedness
and if you practice
manipulating especially if the women
happen to be reasonably good women if
you practice manipulating them and
you're successful then you're learning
to be one you're learning to be one
horrible person now you know as you're
completely useless unproductive and
undesirable former self you weren't
exactly Stellar to begin with but
substituting psychopathy for that what
sort of like substituting cynicism for
naivity now that's a complex problem I
mean part of the reason that people like
Andrew Tate are so attractive to young
guys is because they do put up
that
confident that false
confidence Tate's a complicated guy
because it's not all false you know real
people are complicated the way that like
villains in in comic books aren't
Tate's a fighter it's clearly the case
that he's got a certain degree of
physical bravery that's real all
right there's an element of what he says
that's very attractive to bed bedroom
basement dwelling losers because he's at
least there out in the world you know
taking the blows and he's got a fast car
and he's flashy and he's attractive to
women but a lot of what he's done
especially with women doesn't just
border into the Psychopathic it crosses
the line and that's not a good model
it's not an optimal model for people who
are trying to progress but it's a
strange thing because just as cynicism
is an improvement over naivity right the
capacity to be dark is an improvement
over the lack of ability to be dark at
all and so Tate is attractive in the way
that the shadow beckons to people who
are undeveloped right because it does
it's like you're you're neurotic and
you're dependent and you're repressed
because you're immature and harmless
well one way out of that is to stop
being harmless and one of the things you
can say about Tate is that he's not
harmless right well that's that's a it's
a virtue now it's a virtue that has to
be bracketed it's like cynicism is a
virtue compared to naivity but it's not
it's not virtuous in and of itself it's
a step on the way and so maybe you can
learn to Fain confidence and you can
learn how that works and maybe that's an
improvement I had a guy in my clinical
practice who got involved with the
pickup artist community and he told me
taught me a lot about it and one of the
exercises that their initiates had to do
was to go out and ask 50 women for their
phone number in one day and that's a
great exercise you know and I'm not
exposure therapy approach anxiety
absolutely absolutely getting over your
fear of rejection right and 50 times
they'll do that because you're going to
get rejected the vast majority of times
Well likely 50 times although generally
that wasn't people's experience you know
if if they were even vaguely skilled
they'd at least get a false phone number
out of the deal but then they could they
learn that the rejection wasn't as
catastrophic as they thought but more
importantly they learned that they could
continue moving forward in the face of
rejection so the thing that it makes me
think about there is intellectual
humility and how tightly people hold on
to their beliefs that if you believe
that you are always going to be right
that there is nothing to learn outside
of you and that any kind of admission
that you might be wrong is tant amount
to destruction it does exactly the same
thing you need to and it goes back to uh
asking stupid questions being prepared
to ask the stupid questions and look not
like the most informed person in the
room but also importantly nowhere near
the most stupid person in the room
because you're the one that's asking the
question well the stupidest person in
the room is the person who doesn't know
and won't ask or even worse who doesn't
know and won't ask and acts like they
know yeah that's not good at all yeah
there's a from your see that's part of
that idea that you should love your
enemy so you might say well why should
you do that well your enemy is going to
be your harshest
critic now it's possible that if you
have a very good enemy that he will show
you flaws in your character that you
didn't know were there and so that's a
it's a
very it's a very strange way of looking
at the world to think that you should
welcome an attack you should it and this
is but this is right it yeah I'm saying
that with all due caution let's say the
more the more vicious the
attack the more of your potential hidden
flaws might be revealed have you found
that to be true oh definitely but I've
also found
that the attacks force you to contend
end with it to to see if it's there
right to to test it I suppose the
attacks that have come after me that
have been most successful they they're
almost always journalists and they're
usually British female journalists but
not always we produce a nation of
hard-hitting journalists yeah well and
faith in journalists is the lowest in
the UK and anywhere in the western world
and I can see why you know but there's
some Advantage there's some real
advantage to facing someone it's a
Pharisee problem in in the
gospels Christ was always contending
with these Pharisees and what the
Pharisees were always trying to do was
to lay a verbal trap for him so is a
Pharisee a person Pharisee was a was a
Jewish sect okay and the Pharisees were
very legalistic in their interpretation
of Mosaic law and so they were sort of
they were hypocritical the way they're
portrayed in the gospel SS they're
hypocritical by the book moralists and
and part of what and most of their
morality was for show they like to pray
in public they like to be seen being
holy at least that's the criticisms that
are levied against them and what they're
always trying to do in the gospel
accounts is to lay a verbal trap for
Christ so that they can expose him as a
heretic and kill him right so every
single thing they say is a snare of some
sort and there's lots of journalists
like that Nelly Bulls who wrote an
article about me for the New York Times
which was a very devastating article in
many ways and
very Serpentine and and
subtle she three years
later she wrote another article about
what it was like to work for the New
York Times when she was working there
and the tricks that the journalists
played including her and she said that
the game was to devastate someone else's
reputation in the attempt to boost yours
right so you could think about it as a
game of comparative moral standing so
the journalist's trick is to trick you
into saying something that will end your
career essentially their social status
stands on the shoulders of yours AB
absolutely absolutely and so now the the
advantage to being in a situation like
that is that you have to step if you
step extremely
carefully and you're fortunate then you
evade the traps and then the interview
tilts hard in your favor yeah and so the
most the interviews that have done me
the most good in the long run were the
two interviews that were most hostile
one
by channels 4 Griff Kathy Kathy Newman
Kathy Newman Kathy Griffin and Kathy
Kathy at least had a sense of humor
another one by Helen Lewis who had no
sense of humor at all and doesn't seem
to have learned anything at all in the
interim but I think that I think that
one has 80 million views now twice as
many as the Kathy Newman interview like
it just keeps racking up views and it
was because Helen
Lewis she has like 50 tricks or 100
tricks Kathy had like four you know and
they were pretty blunt and she had a
sense of humor about them but Helen
Lewis she was just all tricks and lots
of them and smart you know and it's
quite something to talk to someone who's
quite smart and quite educated but all
tricks and so but how does it feel
looking back on those two they were very
formative time it was kind of the
inflection point or one of the
inflection points I suppose for yourself
as well yeah how does it feel looking
back on that I remember you said at the
time it took you many days to recover
from that kind of cantankerous sort of
adversarial interview is that does that
seem like a different lifetime or is
that still very much sort of with you
well I'm a lot healthier than I was then
so those sorts of things wouldn't have
the same effect on me now as they did
then because I was Ill it took me a long
time to to recover from you know a
serious bout I mean the first time I
talked to Sam Harris not that Sam played
tricks like I like Sam and we've had
very productive
conversations I was so ill when the
first time I talked to Sam that I could
barely sit in my chair talking to Sam
Harris makes you that's the No No not
not at all no no Sam and I have had very
productive conversations that was
another good example I suppose of the
utility of an adversarial conversation
yeah you know I mean Sam comes to a
conversation like that pretty well armed
but it's very helpful because it forces
you to look in nooks and crannies that
you might not have looked in and to be
crystal clear to the degree that that's
possible about what you're actually
saying the idea of of loving your enemy
is something I've been playing with a
little bit recently this been I guess my
platform's getting to the level now
where uh there's a reason for someone to
have a bullseye pointed at least
remotely in my direction because there's
no point in trying to take somebody down
that's got nothing that's got no status
why would you why would you invest the
time you're the step that you're going
to get in terms of your status standing
on their shoulders is so small that no
one so it's a backhanded compliment yeah
in some ways um but you're right man
some of the some of the criticisms that
I've gotten I was reminded by a friend
recently about this uh have been some of
the best inflection points very
uncomfortable and to see it as a gift to
think about that thing as a gift it's
like know that you weren't doing this to
make me better yeah I know that you
weren't doing this to try and to try and
benefit me and yet and yet yeah in
reflection it's like Alchemy it's like
how Rory Sutherland calls it Alchemy
taking something that was bad I I had
this reflection as well well we we've
learned my family's learned like when
when a public attack occurs there's a
massive opportunity nested in it if you
can reorient it's like okay this is bad
this is vicious this is not this does
not look good
and maybe it could take me out take us
out is there a way is there a way we can
play with this that will not only
neutralize it but twist it in the other
direction I think the thing we did that
was most effective on that side of
things was when I was written into
Captain America as I spoke to you that
day rull I spoke to you that day that it
happened yeah the magical magical super
Nazi floating Nazi or whatever yeah yeah
yeah well it was shocking right it was
it was very shocking and then Olivia
wild yeah the that was shocking too yeah
yeah there's a Litany of yes yes well
and it it became increasingly
Preposterous and and the Olivia wild
episode was one of the that was so
Preposterous that it was almost
immediately mercifully that film was so
badly made and I'm pretty sure that
she'd cast her boyfriend as one of the
got rid of someone that was super
competent and put somebody in that was
pretty incompetent uh and I think that
that kind of caused it to flub but yeah
man the the the enemy thing I've ended
up becoming really good friends with one
of my harshest critics it's so strange
uh and yet makes complete sense
afterward uh you had a how did you end
up making friends so I got criticized uh
by a a pair of podcasters who um do this
they they kind of take down or they have
a very critical eye of much of the of
the podcasting world and they they uh
did an episode about an episode that I'd
done and they have a right of reply
thing oh yeah uh Sam's been on to do it
uh who else has been on to do it I I did
it couple of other constant in kissing
being to do and um I I went on and there
was a bit of like I listened to that
show I think it's a very Illuminating
way to see how people that have a
different perspective about what's going
on in in your world see it and uh I was
like yeah I got the opportunity to go on
and have a conversation and I did and I
found them to both be like way more
Charming than I thought that they were
going to be and I've ended up both Chris
and Matt all Matt less so but with Chris
like we must
speak once a month every couple of weeks
we one of us will just ring and we'll
catch up about what's been going on in
the world and he has a very different
sort of worldview to me he lives in a
different area of the world he's a a a
psychologist studying religion I think
and and uh sacred rituals and stuff like
that rituals rather than
religion and now he points out blind
spot
that I don't see and that one particular
instance was and it was really
uncomfortable because this was still
this was three years ago or something
now maybe and I'm still you super
uncomfortable about it and oh my God
these people are going to take me down
and they're both academics and they're
really really well educated and they're
going to be smart they're going to say
things that make me look silly and I
said things that made me look silly and
picked a particular episode where blah
blah blah and yet in reflection it's
been that one inst
and the subsequent rumination about it
was one of the biggest inflection points
for me going
from having blind spots that I hadn't
seen to that and I I almost think that
the degree of discomfort that I went
through was mandatory because had I not
felt so much like fear and anxiety and
embarrassment about the fact that I'm
going to it's going to be out there and
there going to be all this focus and
attention in not a nice way and there'll
be tweets and all the rest of the
stuff that was sufficiently
uncomfortable to force me to actually
genuinely look at the things that I was
doing that I was getting wrong and I'm
sure that there's a million things I'm
still getting wrong but yeah it was it
was as much a gift as it could be we'll
get back to talking to Jordan in one
minute but first I need to tell you
about element I've used element every
single morning for over three years now
it is the way I start every single day
it tastes fantastic it optimizes my
hydration it helps to regulate my
appetite and it improves my brain health
element contains a science-backed
electrolyte ratio of sodium po potassium
and magnesium best of all they've got a
brand new chocolate caramel flavor which
you can have hot hot element I hear you
say what sort of hydration blasphemy is
this but no it tastes fantastic and on
cold mornings it's perfect there is a no
BS no questions asked refund policy so
you can buy it and try it completely
risk-free and if you do not like it for
any reason they will give you your money
back and you don't even need to return
the Box I've used this every single
morning for as long as I can remember
and that orange flavor is phenomenal
plus that chocolate caramel is available
right now if you go to the link in the
show notes below or head to drink LM
nt.com sodern wisdom for a free sample
pack of all eight flavors with your
first box that's drink LM nt.com
slod wisdom here's another thing I spoke
to David Goggins about this last year
about how uh I was bullied as a kid and
I was quite unpopular in school and I
was an only child so I didn't really
have many people to back me up you know
in the schoolyard or whatever and I for
a long time had a chip on my shoulder
about the kids that mistreated me in
school as you might
expect and then I got toward you know
maybe a few years ago and I really
really started to reflect on it and
realized that so many of the things that
I valued in myself with the light side
of something dark that had been created
during that time in school so um my
complete preparedness to just spend time
on my own means that I don't mind about
moving out to a country where I don't
know anybody and trying to make this
podcast thing work or spending hours and
hours working or researching or
recording podcasts or doing intros or
whatever it is like all of those things
um not having a super tight social
network as a kid meant that I wasn't
beholden to anybody when I grew up that
I I didn't feel the need to have as much
uh um support as I go along to do stuff
now other sides of it haven't been so
great because I still seek validation I
still seek a lot of validation because
that was something that I was missing as
a kid um but yeah realizing not only you
probably wouldn't be here if it wasn't
for the things that you went through
okay there's step one and then step two
is and I'm quite grateful for what I've
done and then step three would be
something like wow I'm proud of myself
for having turned something that was
negative into something that's positive
but then another level above that would
be wow so maybe I should be thankful
yeah right well we know we were talking
earlier in the podcast about what is the
appropriate attitude towards the future
and I would say well we could put past
present and future in the same bin say
well one of the things that you want to
do is practice gratitude that's one of
the primary religious rituals you might
say is the practice of gratitude and you
might say well my life is so horrible
what do I have to be grateful for and I
would say that's
that's for better worse that's still a
form of
blindness right I mean people can have
very very difficult situations can be in
very very difficult situations and it's
in those difficult situations where the
search for gratitude becomes something
that is by necessity deeper and more
difficult but that doesn't mean it's not
appropriate you know and there is there
is a very tight association between
loving your enemy and being
grateful in spite of the terrible things
that occur in your life I've been
writing about the Book of Job and job is
a story of unjust suffering
fundamentally God deems job a good man
so we have it on God's word that job is
actually a good man and then all hell
breaks loose partly because God makes a
bet with Satan which is you know a hell
of a thing to do and says do your worst
he's not not going to turn on me no
matter what you do and so job despite
his
torment he becomes very ill he loses
everything he has his friends he becomes
ill in a way that's disfiguring his
friends come around and laugh at him and
tell him that he's a bad man and that's
why all these terrible things have been
happening to him and it's brutal and job
refuses
to lose faith in himself he says look
I'm I'm not perfect I'm but as far as
men go I've done what I should do
and it I'm not being punished in some
manner that's obviously related to my
sin it's more like the random play
of tragic forces in the world I'm not
going to lose faith in myself no matter
what and I'm also not going to his wife
says shake your fist at God curse him
and die because things have gone so
badly for job she thinks that's all
that's left to him and he refuses to do
that so he maintains
Faith regardless of what's happened to
him and that's really the moral of the
story of job which is that you are
morally obligated to maintain Faith no
matter what happens to you and there's a
practical side to that so imagine that
God and Satan conspire against you
there'll be times in your life where it
feels like that's happening and then
imagine that your reaction to that is to
become bitter and res resentful and
hostile well then whatever hell you're
in merely as a consequence of the
Confluence of tragic events you have
opened a whole other hell underneath it
the hell of bitterness and resentment
and ingratitude and well and that turns
into the desire for Revenge very very
quickly you think things are bad just
because they're bad you wait till you
see how bad they can become if you allow
yourself to be corrupted by your unjust
suffering
right and so it's just and I I I do
think that this is the most practical
possible advice that can be given to
people which is that you are morally
required to maintain Faith to aim up and
to treat other people the way you would
want to be treated no matter what's
happened to you you know and that's a
hell of a thing to say and you know you
might say well that's impossible PE some
people have such brutal lives that
they're destined to be corrupt but I
would say that's not true like I've met
many people particularly in my clinical
practice who had lives that were so
brutal that you couldn't even listen to
them without it like breaking you into
pieces brutal brutal childhoods of of a
depth of malevolence you can hardly
conceptualize who decided despite that
that they were going to aim up and they
were going to maintain faith in
themselves and the world and so it's
like that's on the table for people it
seems like an odd paradox that the
people who have been brought up under
lives of the most privileged are often
the ones that have the most complaints
about the world and people who have been
brought up in deprivation a lot of the
time are able to be perfectly in
gratitude it seems very strange that
that that's the way yeah well
I
having so one of the things I saw at the
University I saw the faculty members my
peers retreat in the face of the
advancement of the Administration over
like three decades to the point where
the universities really became corrupted
and it didn't really happen at Harvard
when I was there in the 1990s although
it was starting to fray around the edges
slightly but I really watched it at the
University of Toronto in the 20 years I
was there the administration kept making
demands on us and every time they made a
demand we would fold every time 10,000
micro Retreats so then the
administrators took over the university
and then the woke types took over the
administration and that was that well
the reason what I saw my faculty members
do the academics that I worked with is
that this is how the corruption starts
it's like when you're an undergraduate
you write down what you think the
professor wants to hear to get the grade
and then you're a graduate student and
you you have to let's say get along with
your professors and your supervisor you
have to tell them what you think they
want to hear so that you can get your
PhD and then maybe you are on the
academic track and you're an assistant
professor there's three levels of being
a professor you're not tenur as an
assistant so you really can't say what
you think or do what you think you
should do then because you have to get
tenur and then when you're tenure well
you're not a full Professor yet and so
you don't speak then and back in the
back of your mind you have this idea
well at some point I'll have enough
security so that I'll be able to tell
tell the truth but that's based on this
weird idea that the courage to tell the
truth is based on
security well courage isn't based on
security that's a stupid Theory you're
not courageous if there's no risk so
your notion is you'll be
courageous when there's zero risk well
obviously that's a contradiction in
terms you're only courageous if there's
a risk and not only that by the time
you've sacrificed your word for for
illusory security for 15 years there's
nothing left of you that's true you've
already that's gone a long time ago you
you probably look back at the former
self who was naive and thought that you
could say what you think as
just well you're bit you're cynical
about it you know that person just
didn't know how the way didn't know how
the world worked and then it's the same
thing that you pointed
out the idea that you become good
because you
have material plenty that's a silly idea
why would that be the case it's like the
same as assuming that all rich people
have got taste right poor people who've
got beautifully designed interiors and
rich people who've got gy messes right
right right right there was yeah well
then the poor people are actually
rich absolutely uh there's a a report I
wanted to bring this to you it's so
interesting so the recent report was
released by The Harvard Graduate School
of Education detailing the drivers of
anxiety for young adults aged 18 to 25
34% reported feelings of loneliness 51%
said achievement pressure negatively
impacted their mental health 58%
reported lacking meaning or purpose in
their lives in the last month 50%
reported their mental health was
negatively influenced by not knowing
what to do with my life there has been
much examination of the well-being of
teens a 14 to 17 not much has been known
about those occupying the critical young
adult years and yet young adults report
roughly twice the rates of anxiety and
depression as teens the young adults are
not okay
mhh yeah I believe that I saw even with
my own kids that the the mo like when I
was a
kid probably the time between 13 and 15
was the most difficult transition but I
saw that become older
by the time my kids my kids are 30 now
basically by the time my kids were young
adults I could see that that transition
into adulthood was the place where the
difficulties were starting to
mount I think perversely that the
therapeutic world has a fair bit to do
with this partly
because therapists who are
basically secular liberal Protestants
that's a good way of thinking about them
tend to conceptualize mental health as
mental as subjective right is like
mental health is something you carry
around in your head like you carry
around your identity that's why we have
these ridiculous ideas that you can just
Define your own identity I am whoever I
say I am well obviously you're not
because other people other people have
to go along with your game their buddy
and they're either going to do that
they're not going to do it or they're
going to do it voluntarily or they're
going to do it by force if they're not
going to do it you're screwed if you
have to use Force that's not going to
work and if you want them to do it
voluntarily then it's not going to be
all about you obviously even no
four-year-old can find someone to play
with if he always gets to pick the game
okay
so why might young adults be lost well
part of it is that they're
thinking I'm not trying to be judgmental
of a whole generation it's a it's a form
of
thought your mental health isn't
dependent on you that's not the right
way to think about
it you I don't think you can be mentally
healthy in the absence of a long-term
stable relationship so you have to be
married let's put let's let's make that
part of the precondition for successful
adaptation as a young adult you have to
be married so you have to establish a
relationship with someone that
integrates sexuality that's there for
the long run because there for the long
run is the same is
sane there for tomorrow there for the
next minute that's not sanity that's
impulsiveness that's aimlessness they're
the same thing if it's what if it's all
about what you want right now or more
accurately all about what something in
you wants this moment that's the
definition of immature insanity
you have to commit so you commit to
someone else you commit to your family
you commit to your community like there
are multiple levels of identity that
stretch out into the social world and
voluntarily adopting those levels of
hierarchical responsibility gives you an
identity it gives you a purpose it
protects you from anxiety it does that
in all sorts of ways like you know you
said earlier that one of the things you
do is seek for validation and you
related that to uncomfortable experience
you had when you were very young well it
might not be precisely that you're
seeking for validation you might be
properly investigating how you should be
embedded in a social
hierarchy at every possible level it's
like well people think their mental
health is something that they just carry
around in their head and that if they
just got the way they looked at the
world right or if other people just
played their game that all of a sudden
they'd be mentally healthy it's like
there's no difference between thinking
about yourself and being
miserable technically if you if you if
you look at you can you can
group descriptive statements about
yourself
statistically all the all the
descriptive all the descriptors that are
reflective of self-consciousness load on
negative emotion can you not think about
yourself in a positive
way probably not really
not well let's take that
apart you like doing your podcast and
you feel positive about it okay but your
podcast isn't about
you right so if you're thinking about
how you're of utility to a broad number
of people you know maybe you would take
some satisfaction in that but that isn't
exactly thinking about yourself is it
it's thinking about the relationship
you've established with other people and
it's a relationship of responsibility
why do you like your podcast you can
pursue what you're curious about but you
wouldn't have to do that publicly okay
so why do you do it
publicly for a few reasons first one
being that it keeps me accountable that
was one of the main reasons that it kept
me accountable because I knew that if I
didn't do it if I wasn't rigorous and
precise and uh aligned with what I'd
said and done previously that there was
an external eye that's watching keep
okay okay so well that's very
interesting so I would also say that's
not exactly about you that's about your
ability to live to establish Harmony
between what you say and the way you act
and the expectations that an
increasingly Broad Social Community has
of you as a consequence of what you say
and how you act okay that's not about
you that's about your nest
in a social hierarchy right and so I
think I think you can and then you might
say too well maybe you're thinking about
yourself when you're establishing an aim
or a goal well not if they're good aims
or
goals because if they're good aims or
goals and and I would say what good
means technically is an aim or goal that
will play out
well in the medium to long term across a
multitude of situations including many
many people so the a solution that
iterates across
time that and that
is situation independent and that's
broadly socially inclusive is a better
aim right it's a higher aim because it
integrates more all right now you might
want to be setting up aims and you might
be pleased about how you're progressing
in relation to those aims but if those
aims aren't don't have the
characteristics that I just
described
then if the aims have the
characteristics I just described they're
not about you and then we could also ask
what do you mean about you exactly what
you are you talking about here you know
and so we play these identity games in
the modern world that are making people
anxious and hopeless and one identity
game is I'm defined by my sexuality okay
so let's take that I'm defined by my
sexuality okay but what do you mean by
your sexuality exactly do you mean the
opportunity to engage in sex like are
you reducing sexuality as such to the
act of sex okay let's say you are so now
what you're telling me is that who you
are is who you are when you're sexually
desirous that's what you've reduced
yourself to but it's even more than that
it's the kind of sexual desire that
wants gratification right now with no
relationship whatsoever so not only have
you now reduced who you are to your
sexual desire you've reduced your sexual
desire to the minimal set of
preconditions that would satisfy it well
then the first question that might come
up there is why not just use porn it's a
lot simpler and the answer to that is
that is what people are doing well it's
no wonder that they're anxious and
Lonesome and aimless because they've
they've reduced themselves to a
short-term desire they've found the
easiest possible way of gratifying that
and they've abandoned everything that
would be a much broader
conceptualization of what sexuality
would be if it was embedded properly in
well how about a relationship to start
with and I'm not
just these aren't just opinions
so there are two different strategies of
reproduction broadly in the animal world
one is zero investment
fish mosquitoes million Offspring they
all die but one right so you can reduce
reproduction in mosquitoes basically to
sex and you make a million mosquito
Offspring all you need is one to survive
problem solved okay on the opposite end
of the spectrum literally are human
beings because we have the longest
dependency period of any animal by a
large margin we have a high investment
strategy sexual reproduction strategy so
whatever sex is for human beings isn't
you're off and that's over that's not
what it is for human beings it's
embedded in a relationship now you might
say well we could pull sexuality out of
the relationship and just indulge in it
for the pleasure okay so now let's
forget about all the other animals now
we've got two types of human being we've
got the one nightst human being
repetitive one night St and we've got
the long-term committed relationship
human being and then we might ask okay
what are the the personality
characteristics of the people in those
bins so let's go to the short-term one
night stand sequential relationship
types okay who are they Psychopathic
narcissistic mellian and sadistic all
one night stand
people if they don't start out that way
they're going to end that
way right because you can't use yourself
or other people for short-term
gratification
look the definition of a psychopath is
someone who uses someone for short-term
gratification okay so it's
definitional right so and then you might
say well I'm not like that I just like
sex it's like yeah but if you practice
that for five years are you're not going
to become what you practice you know
and I talked to Russell Brand about this
a little bit on and I can say this
because it was on his podast so it's not
like this is secret you know Russell had
what Andrew Tate promises his followers
he had Fame he was
charismatic and he had more or less
unlimited access to short-term sexual
gratification okay in combination with
you know the chemicals that make that
even more likely alcohol and cocaine
let's
say so what are the consequences well I
asked him what were the consequences you
had this he said uh despair anxiety and
hopelessness right but but not just that
because you know Russell got himself in
trouble here month and a half ago just
about took him out well it was his past
coming back to haunt him like and he had
to scroll through his psyche and see you
know well in with all these short-term
relationships these
short-term sexual gratification binges
that I indulged in did I ever cross the
line well the answer is well you're
going to have like 200 encounters like
that you're not going to cross the line
when you're drunk when you're on cocaine
you're going to cross a bunch of lines
and then it's going to come back and
haunt you and
so it's very interesting to see in our
culture back to the hopelessness and
despair that were mentioning that's
characterizing young adults life it's
like well it's all about me that's the
self-esteem movement but then me becomes
it's all about what I want and then that
becomes it's all about what I want right
now then it's it's what the lowest part
of me wants right now and to hell with
everyone else it's like
okay how are you going to play that game
without being desperate you're going to
be desperate as soon as you start
playing that game and the other thing
it's even worse than that because you're
going to end up with
the Jeremy the the the porn star problem
anybody you're not going to be very
happy about being with the people who
want to play that game with you because
they're not going to be the people that
are really going to make you feel that
life is worth living they're going to be
the people especially on the female
side women who are willing to take
advantage of themselves for short-term
sexual gratification those aren't happy
women they're usually damaged women and
if they're not damaged when they start
playing that game they're going to be
plenty damaged by the time they're done
with it the last time that we spoke me
and you talked about population Decline
and the Census Bureau just released
today predicting that the US population
will decline for the first time ever by
the year 2100 after peaking in 2080 so
their estimates showed that the US
population which is about 333 million at
the moment is expected to reach 370 by
2080 but will be back down to 366 by
2100 and even immigration can't offset
this birth rate
decline over the last 2 years do you
think things have got better or worse
than you anticipated from birth rate and
marriage rate standpoint I think they're
probably still getting
worse uh and I think
musk musk is one of the few people Elon
Musk is one of in case anybody was
wondering um he's one of the few people
who who's called out the danger of you
know a one child policy or the idea that
we should decrease the population I
mean things that don't grow die but they
die for all sorts of reasons and we
could we could tie this back to Identity
you know what's my identity I could say
well it's how I feel about myself that's
that's the line that's used everywhere
now you don't get to tell me who I am I
know who I am I can I'm who I feel I am
well first of all I don't even know what
you mean by feel like what what the hell
what does that mean you're your
emotional state at the moment and you
can just impose that on everybody that's
your theory is it that's the theory of a
2-year-old literally that's a very bad
Theory
well where could your identity be other
than that well one of my identities when
I taught at Harvard was Professor
obviously and that was a good identity
but you know that wasn't exactly it
wasn't something I was carrying around
my head it was a pattern of relationship
that I had with a whole bunch of people
all my students right it wasn't inside
my head now there was a concordance
between my representation of myself and
how I was acting in the world and that
concordance was the health it wasn't
what I thought of myself you
like part of the reason that you can
take some let's call it gratification
from being a successful podcaster is
that you're actually a successful
podcaster it's not in your head it's in
1.5 million subscribers it's how many
podcast have you done 700 okay so it's
in 700 podcast it's not something you're
carrying around in your head do you
remember I love the 42 Rules that
created the 24 that you ended up coming
up with but there's one that you didn't
use uh if you have to choose be the one
who does things right not the one who is
seen to do things exactly absolutely I
love that rule oh yeah that's a great
rule that's a great rule yeah well the
thing is is that you can do almost
anything you want if you're willing to
take responsibility for it if you don't
want credit one of the most effective
political maneuver I've ever seen woman
who's she's so brilliant I won't tell
you who she is but she's so sharp she's
so brilliant and she told me the last
time I saw her she's had her finger in
pies for like 30 years popping up in
places you'd never expect I thought I
asked just like how the hell did you
pull this off and she said oh I decided
30 years ago that
I could do whatever I wanted if I didn't
want credit and so that's exactly what
she's done and she's had a stellar
career stellar and I've worked with
other people who've done the same thing
it's very interesting it's very
interesting thing to realize you might
say well why would I want the
responsibility without the glory it's
like hey do you want the glory are you
so sure that that wouldn't just get in
your way you know there's something to
be said for anonymity and second maybe
you want the responsibility cuz that's
the adventure you actually get to do the
thing that someone else just wants to
take credit for well maybe doing the
thing is plenty of reward in and of
itself with regard to
Identity you know when when I was a
professor I was also a husband and I was
also a father well those were identities
but they weren't in my head they were
embedded in the relationship I had with
my kids and that was a meaningful
relationship embedded in the
relationship I had with my wife you
can't be you know it's almost heretical
to say this in the modern
world you can't be isolated alone
without responsibility and pursuing your
hedonistic
nonsense and not be insane and miserable
those are all the same thing right and
so you know it's got to the point i'
I've said things that have made me
somewhat unpopular like it's very
difficult for people to mature until
they have a
child
you find a huge part of what you are in
that relationship it makes you
responsible makes you grow up it gives
you the opportunity to Mentor someone
you have someone around who's more
important than you well that's part of
being mentally healthy it's a huge part
of it this is this Enterprise that I put
together in London helped put together
Alliance for responsible citizenship
we're trying to put forward a model of
governance it's called subsidiary model
model and the idea is
that people have multiple social roles
that scale know there's you should take
care of yourself integrate yourself
which means you can conduct yourself
properly across the medium to long run
your self- sustaining then you can maybe
extend that to your partner and then to
your family and then to your local
community and then to broader
communities as you become more and more
competent and able to take on that
responsibility that's the alternative to
isolated hedonic slavery you slave to
your own whims and it's the alternative
to tyranny because if you take on all
that responsibility you don't have any
need for someone to govern you and so
that's another example of
how I blamed it on the therapists a
little bit I called them liberal
Protestant
secularists and that's
because they think about the Locust of
the psyche as
interior subjective that's what a
liberal would do it's just not accurate
that isn't that isn't the way the psyche
works it's not in your head you know
it's it's in your head and in the world
at the same time it's truly the case
that your sanity is the concordance
between you as an individual and the
world that's the sanity it's not the
proper structure of your psyche or your
brain for that matter inside your skull
you're distributed out into the world
and you should be and that's you want to
be that's where the adventure is you
want to be solipsistic the solipsistic
porn masturbator Jesus it's no wonder
you be aimless and miserable well God
it's so pathetic why am I so unhappy
it's because you think about yourself no
you think about the lowest impulses in
yourself all the time that's why you're
miserable whilst being Arc what I
thought was particularly interesting was
your live event that you guys did at the
O2 on the evening time and everyone was
great but Douglas I thought was just a t
to force that evening what have you
learned since being friends with Douglas
how's he impacted you or influenced
you well douglas douglas is very very
disagreeable you know and he enjoys
combat and that isn't something that
really characterizes I don't enjoy
combat at all I mean part of the reason
that it's perverse I suppose in some
ways part of the reason that I will
engage
in difficult conversations is because I
don't want to have them
forever and so you know one of the rules
I had in my marriage and it was a rule
that my wife also so was pleased to
follow was that if we have a problem
we're going to deal with it right now
and we're going to deal with it right to
the bottom and that's very unpleasant
but if you do
it sometimes you only have to do it once
and the problem goes away and then you
don't have that Bloody problem every day
for the rest of your life and sometimes
it takes you know 20 times before it's
fixed before you've got to the bottom of
things and that can be very
unpleasant Douglas is very very good
at not letting people off the hook he's
very tough and he's very good at
defending himself
and in he there's a pitilessness about
him that's extraordinarily admirable
it's a judicious pitilessness you know
and it's a dangerous game to play
because there's another gospel
realization let's say is the standards
you judge other people by will be the
standards that you yourself are judged
by and the reason for that is well how
are you going to judge everyone else and
not apply the same standards to yourself
like that's not going to happen because
you become what you practice and you'll
turn the eye the Hostile eye that you
turn on others you will absolutely turn
on yourself there's there's no way
around that and so Douglas plays a
dangerous game because he's very
combative but he's also extremely
careful he's very careful with his words
and
we've had a he toured with me through
Europe I think we did nine shows
together we we split the Q&A he intro he
did a little bit of an introduction
before my lectures I really liked it I
thought it was great it's been a
privilege to get to know him super sharp
um very cultured person um very witty so
he has a great sense of humor which is
also fun which also is one of the things
that makes him a very dangerous opponent
in a debate because not only
does he have the facts at hand like bun
lomberg but he's devastatingly witting
witty and cutting and it's fun to watch
that he's a master at it so it was uh
it's interesting to think about the fact
that all you need really in a live
debate I think I learned this from you
and Sam ages ago if you're doing a live
debate now that's not a proper
intellectual formatted opening remarks
so on and so forth if you manage to get
sort of two or three real zingers you
won regardless of the content if you do
two or three real Zinger whole crowd
laughs guess what you you got yeah well
the great public intellectuals have a
vicious sense of humor right and I mean
I also think that's why so many of the
successful podcasters have been
comedians well at the ark conference I
think Constantine Ken's speech was the
overwhelming hit of the convention I
think it's got 600,000 views as of today
650 on the ark side and about 600 on his
own channel and Constantine did a
beautiful job of merging intellectual
content with wit well the thing the
interesting thing about uh my live tour
that I'm about to start doing bunch of
my comedian friends have said to me dude
I am so jealous of the tour that you get
to do because no one's expecting you to
be funny if you manag to be funny four
times in 90 minutes you've killed if I'm
not funny once every 7 seconds I'm a
[__] comedian right right so the bar is
set and obviously coming in with
Constantine's background of Comedy means
that he is able to be by far the you
know far in away way funnier than most
public speakers uh but doesn't get held
necessarily to the same standards that
he he's not expecting to be one liners
all the time one of the things that
Douglas brought up when you guys were
talking on stage that I thought was
particularly interesting was The Perils
of smart people getting captured by
culture wars [__] do you ever think
about how much time over the last decade
some of the smartest people on the
planet have had their attention their
cognitive horsepower just yeah taken
away arguing about whether men are men
and women are women or not or whatever
the idea dour of the day is yeah well
this time been lost so I've been
partnering with the daily wire for about
about a year and a half so far that's
been very successful they've been a
pleasure to work with but what they
wrestle with constantly all of them all
of the principles all of the principles
at Daily wire would rather in some real
way be be concentrating on philosophical
theological or dramatic matters so which
is partly why the daily wire is turning
towards entertainment for kids but also
for adults starting to make movies for
example and TV shows they'd rather be
doing that I had Ben
Shapiro um he participated in this
seminar on Exodus that I produced with
about nine other um extraordinarily
interesting thinkers and Ben is Shawn
you know he he's he's
wasted is he wasted on the
political the political is necessary but
it's it's one nation under God for a
reason because the political the
political isn't the Pinnacle never it's
never the Pinnacle and if you're capable
of discourse at the Pinnacle political
discourse is secondary there it's also
evanescent right there's ways that it
can tumble as well there's uh how would
you say degrees of depth of political
stuff too because what works on YouTube
a lot of the time is and reacts to
insane woke Tik Tok exactly and it's
easy to get pigeonholed that way yeah
yeah and it is is it a
waste it's nonoptimal but it's a
question it's an interesting question to
be asked right about how how much sort
of ankle or skirt or neede you need to
show from an algorithmic perspective in
order to keep the numbers churning
because ultimately you're producing what
people click on you don't want to be
completely beholden to your audience
that's audience capture but you also
don't want to be so unaware of having
your finger on the pulse of what is
trendy that you become obscure and
obsolete right right well in it and that
well in that line that you're trying to
walk when you're dealing with matters
that are the highest and also making
them publicly accessible that's a very
very tight line to walk I mean Jonathan
Paso has done a good job of that
although his Market is still relatively
Niche and he certainly is more esoteric
let's say than the daily wire guys who
tend to devolve into the political and
that devolves into the cheap political
from time to time right the hit for hit
sake or the or the chasing the algorithm
and I mean that's the danger that all
politicians have too is that and I've
seen this with lots of political types
who have developed a
Persona this is particularly true in the
United States I would say because
Americans are so salesman and I don't
say that dismissively it's really hard
to sell to Market to
communicate I I saw the Elvis movie
recently and I thought it did a
beautiful job of laying this out because
Elvis was a stellar talent but his
manager who is a real Shyer was also a
stellar Talent like wouldn't have been
who he was without his corrupt manager
and you know it's sort of a deal with
the devil but you have to give the devil
is due too and the salesman part of
American culture can easily devolve into
a kind
of
narcissistic manipulativeness that's
that's where it would go if it becomes
pathological but as you said you have to
be aware of your audience and you have
to be delivering what there's a market
for and it's very very difficult to get
those things right this is a question
that I've got about your new book coming
out next year I haven't seen any of it
and it's sounds like based on what
you're reading at the moment you're
trying to Grapple with religious texts
especially the Bible we who wrestle with
God is the name of the book we who
wrestle with God yeah which is the
that's what the word Israel means Israel
means we who wrestle with God and so
well it's very interesting because it
means the chosen people are the people
who wrestle with God and you might say
well who wrest with God and the answer
to that is well everyone wrestles with
god well why because you can't act
without making moral decisions like
every every step forward is predicated
on a moral decision and so we're all
wrestling with God is God a moral
decision God is the spirit that guides
you when you make the proper moral
decisions so I wouldn't say God is a
moral decision ision he's the spirit of
he's the spirit of moral decision that's
that's actually not a bad definition
like part of what I'm trying to do with
this book is to point out that a lot of
what's happening in the biblical Corpus
is actually
definitional right
well people modern people think the
fundamental issue is do you believe in
God but that's not the fundamental issue
the fundamental issue is what do you
mean by God and so let me give you an
example of this that will make clearer
so there's all there's a medieval idea
that God is the sum bonum which means
the sum of all that's good or the
essence of all that's good okay you
might say well I don't believe in that
now remember this is a definition of God
right God is the sum of all that's good
okay all right so you don't believe in
that all right let's take that
apart do you believe that some things
are better than other things well people
will say yes okay so then you believe
that there is a
scale of
good okay is there something that all
things that are good share in common and
the answer that has to be yes because
otherwise you don't have a conception of
good right the word good implies that
across good things there's some Essence
okay well the definition the medieval
one medieval definition of God is the
essence of good well okay let's say you
don't believe in that okay does that
mean you don't believe in anything
that's good
okay then how how do you act then
because to act means to do something
that's better than what you're doing now
right there's no action without movement
towards the the good and well you might
you might say well I don't believe that
there's a unitary good okay you believe
there's there's a fractionated good well
then what do you do when those things
oppose one another right which would be
in a conflict of Duty what how do you
refer to what do you refer to to help
you adjudicate between different Goods
well generally what you do is if you
could pursue a which is good or B which
is good and they conflict then you pick
the higher good okay do you believe in a
higher good well if you don't you can't
decide between goods which means you're
paralized if you do believe in the
higher good then do you believe in the
highest good well the highest good is
God what do you mean by that by
definition okay so now you have a
definition now then the next question
might be
well what's your relationship with the
highest good and you might say well I
don't have a relationship it's like well
actually you do because you act in
relationship to it you can't help it you
one of the interesting things about the
biblical Corpus is that it's based on
the insistence that you have a
relationship with being and becoming a
relationship like a personal
relationship when you say biblical culus
do you mean the collection of texts that
makes up the Bible yeah because it's a
library of of books essentially right
the Bible is actually the first library
of books it's written by a v a very
large number of different people and
aggregated over thousands of years and
then
sequenced actually sequenced into a
narrative interestingly enough because
no one really sequenced it or by no one
I mean no individual person it was the
Endeavor of the collective or the spirit
that possessed the collective over
thousands of years but the narrative is
coherent which is really quite something
and so the narrative is an investigation
number one into the nature of God number
two into the nature of relationship with
God and then number three into the
nature of the proper relationship with
God all of those things and God
is the sum of all that's good so the
Bible is an analysis of H the human
relationship with the good
what what would have to happen after the
publishing of we who wrestle with God
for you to look back on that publication
and consider it a success what is it
that you want to happen what do you want
people to feel or to take away from that
work I think we're at the beginning of
the counter
Enlightenment the the propositions the
enlightenment view of man is is wrong
and this you know out of the
Enlightenment view came science but the
Science Now indicates that the
enlightenment view of man is wrong what'
you mean well the enlightenment types
believe that we could Orient ourselves
in the world let's say empirically that
and this is Sam Harris's
proposition you can abide by the facts
you can Orient yourself as a consequence
of the dispassionate analysis of the
facts you can't and I would say the
artificial intelligence Engineers have
figured that out the postmodern literary
critics have figured that out the
psychologists and physiologists of
perception have figured it out and the
neuroscientists have figured that out so
it's not just the evidence that that
view is necessarily incorrect is
overwhelming and
multi-dimensional you can't Orient
Yourself by the facts why because there
are as many facts as there are things in
fact if you combine
things the nature of the combination is
also a fact so there's as many facts as
there are things and combinations of
things well you can't Orient Yourself by
that that's you drown in chaos it's like
you're standing in the desert and
there's an infinite number of directions
you could go well how do you choose a
direction and that's showing up in that
most recent survey that I just mentioned
people feeling meaninglessness
purposelessness I'm overwhelm lost in
the desert they're lost in the desert
that's and the desert is the desert of
fact it's dead facts especially given
how few people can agree on is this a
fact or is this counter the well that's
also a problem is it's not like the
facts are necessarily self-evident some
facts are and I suppose to some degree
what the scientific Corpus is is the
elaboration of a set
of incontrovertible facts I've read
recently that the whole big bang
narrative is starting to come apart you
know that was a fact for a long time now
I don't know if that's the case I don't
know enough about it but my sense is
that the new discoveries from the web
telescope have made many of the
presumptions upon which the Big Bang
model was based questionable so now I
don't want to you know fall down a
postmodern rabbit hole
because although the issue of what
constitutes a fact is a very complicated
issue anyways you can cut to the chase
by pointing out that we organize facts
in a hierarchy of value and see the
thing about I'm trying to make this case
in the
book you do this when you look at the
world you can't look at the world except
through a hierarchy of value so for
example as we're sitting here there's an
infinite number of places is we could be
pointing our eyes like I could be
talking to you and looking at this
little spot on the concrete floor or the
spot beside it or the infinite number of
spots surrounding it constantly but I'm
not I'm looking at your eyes okay why
because I'm prioritizing them so the
fact that dominates in this landscape is
the fact of your eyes
why I can use your eyes to evaluate our
shared Focus
right and that's why we look at other
people's eyes it's also why humans have
got white around theide exactly it's so
that we can see what other people are
attending to so that we can get insight
into the story a story is a
description of a hierarchy of value
stories can be Fantastical though right
if they're untethered to anything I can
make up Harry Potter's a story now
there's if they're untethered to
anything you won't find them interesting
because they won't resonate they they
won't grip you m
yeah they're they're tethered stories
are Tethered to reality in a very very
complicated
way because reality isn't what presents
itself moment to moment
it's our
math there's a huge debate among
philosophers about mathematical
abstractions are they real well you
could make a case that a mathem matical
abstraction is more real than the thing
from which it's abstracted how would you
make that case if you're a master of
mathematics you master the world so are
the mathematical abstractions more or
less real narrative abstractions are
abstractions but you could
say this is what an archetype is an
archetype is a narrative abstraction
that's more real than the world than the
apparent world it's behind the scenes
and the biblical Corpus is a is a
narrative it's a hyperreal narrative
that's the right way to think about it
it's more real than real it's more real
than reality how could something that
isn't the thing be more real than the
thing well that's exactly the problem
with
abstraction right is the idea of a
church more real than a given
Church well it is in some ways CU it
encapsulates what's similar across all
churches right so it it's like a
platonic ideal a category is like a
platonic ideal is it more or less real
well you could say that the reality this
is what Plato said the reality is a dim
shadow of the essence the reality is
less real than the ideal and we we
certainly and that's actually in some
ways built into our perception like we
we
criticize we criticize the things that
present themselves to us because they
are poor reflections of the hypothetical
ideal you might say well the ideal isn't
real it's like
well you could make the O opposite
argument which is that the ideal is more
real than the thing itself and I mean I
can give you an example of these
patterns so in the story of Cain and
Abel you have two patterns of
sacrifice okay why is sacrifice an issue
the reason it's an issue is because
people exist in a sacrificial
relationship to the world what does that
mean it seems to to mean something like
human beings are aware of their extended
self you know you're going to be around
tomorrow and next week and next month
and next year and 5 years from now and
10 years from now now it's less certain
as you go out but you do have the sense
of yourself as something that stretches
across the decades okay and so what that
means is that you have to conduct
yourself in a manner that isn't merely
immediate you have to conduct yourself
in a manner that will work across time
now how do people do that they work work
is a sacrificial gesture so you
work by definition virtually work is the
sacrifice of the present for the future
I mean maybe someone can come up with a
better definition of work than that but
I don't think so it's like you you put
in time and effort right now it's
something even if it's something maybe
not what you'd like to be doing at the
moment you put in time and effort
because you believe what the hell does
that mean you believe it'll pay off well
is that a
contract with the future is it a
covenant because the relationship that
the biblical
Corpus insists characterizes human
striving is covenantal it's a bargain
the bargain is you make the right
sacrifices and they pay off that's the
bargain now you might say well that's
just part of the social contract but the
biblical Corpus insists that it's deeper
than that it's built into the structure
of reality itself and that if you got
the sacrifices right the future would be
paradisal I've got it in my head that K
young quote beware of unearned
wisdom that feels like that feels like
it plays a role here like
how the work that you need to put in in
order to be able to arrive at genuinely
knowing the thing the difference between
actually being attracted because who you
are is attractive and you being able to
be a pickup artist that is able to make
the mouth noises and the hand gestures
that caus those are the fruits of false
sacrifice you could say that unearned
unearned moral reputation is the
consequence of false sacrifice well this
is performative empathy right sure
exactly on interet definitely that's the
same as praying in public look at how
good I am if the look at if the look at
comes before the how good I am right
right right right it really uh reeks
havoc on the good claim it's also I
spoke to Douglas about this it seems to
almost be a predictor it's an identifier
that you should be a little bit more
cautious about what this person is doing
definitely you know if every single
person that's super sweety and nicey
nicey lizo do you see lizo was in the
news recently no so she is a uh artist
singer uh she the one that that got in
trouble for abusing her close
compatriots dancers yeah she made her
dancers eat bananas out of the vaginas
of Amsterdam and strippers um Douglas
said that he oh yeah that's a little on
the hedonistic power mad side well she
was supposed to be you know this bass
like f the girls and body positivity and
all this stuff but it turned out behind
the scenes that she was treating her
dancers terribly body shaming them all
of the time but she was the one up front
M that was the Vanguard of this
particular movement but you'd seen the
same with uh was it Jimmy Fallon I think
he was uh caught up in a fural recently
that he was a tyrant to work for and yet
out front Ellen degenerous again the
same it's almost actually like if
somebody is it's very much like that
overloading on the sweetie nicey I am
here for the underlings that you
go I'm a little bit suspicious of what's
going on
there if you need to Proclaim your
Purity and your good
standing if it's all words and opinions
and not Deeds one of The Commandments
one of the Ten Commandments is do not
use God's name in vain okay now people
think that means don't swear and it sort
of means that that's one of its like
tangential meanings but what it really
means is do not
claim Divine motivation for self-serving
Behavior right and that's performative
compassion so what you do is you elevate
compassion to the highest place so you
make it your goal which is a big mistake
because whatever God is he is not merely
compassion you elevate compassion to the
highest place and then you say I feel
sorry for people and what that does is
elevate your moral status to the highest
possible place right it's completely
unearned because this is something JK
Rowling got so accurate with her Dolores
Umbridge character right he was an
absolute power M with little kittens had
the kittens on the plates it's like this
toxic sentimentality I'm so nice it's
like yeah I'd like to stay away from you
and you're devouring niceness and the
freudians knew about that very very in a
very sophisticated way very early
because the devouring mother the edle
mother is the shadow side of compassion
I've been trying to come up with the
term for this for a while I like meing
things into existence giving them names
useful uh and at the moment the best one
I've got is the the shallow Pond of
empathy which is at the
moment something which appeases people
and does not cause them any discomfort
immediately is always prioritized even
if the net effect of that over the long
term results in their suffering
absolutely that's exactly what that's
exactly what the edle situation is it's
the prioritization of short-term
emotional Comfort over medium to
long-term thriving right cuz the mother
who kicks the child out of the nest says
this is going to hurt now but the
iterating consequences are positive
Michelangelo's PA done right exactly
that's right that's right and it's
that's exactly right and the and the
moral of that story is is that if you
give up your children to the world you
will keep them right that's the
sacrifice of Abraham is Abraham is
called upon by God to sacrifice his son
and he says yes so he doesn't have to
right you have to offer up your children
to be broken by the world or you lose
them you undermine them you destroy them
it's very it's a very paradoxical truth
we were talking about
patterns Cain is the pattern of
inappropriate sacrifice he does
everything second rate he lies he omits
he prevaricates he pretends he doesn't
offer his best Able's the opposite he
offers his best which means he's
his light is shining on the hill right
there's no hiding he's giving it
everything he's got the Covenant with
God is that if you give it everything
you've got you will prevail and that's
what God tells Cain which to go through
some of the threads from today Instinct
staying true to that instinct honesty
saying what you mean not prioritizing
avoiding uh someone else's or your
discomfort in the short term in order to
believe that this something which is
going to make you feel better over the
long term I have a well that's a kind of
sacrifice right there is that you're
willing to sacrifice your
short-term physiological and
psychological comfort for a medium to
long-term benefit it's the essence of
sacrifice to offer the this is this is
something the atheists don't understand
about the biblical narrative is that the
narrative insists that we live in a
sacrificial relationship it's the
essence of humanity to live in a
sacrificial relationship it's like well
is that true or not
well as you
mature your relationships are more
sacrificial it's less about what you in
your narrow sense want right now and
it's more about what's good over the
medium to long run including other
people well that's a sacrificial
relationship now the Covenant you know
and this is a matter of Faith it's the
matter of the deepest
Faith do you are you willing to act out
the proposition that
the way to make the world reveal itself
to you in its most positive guise is for
you to adopt the most appropriate
sacrificial relationship well it's a big
risk isn't it because you have to give
up everything that's the that's the deal
you give up everything that's low
everything everything well that's what
the Christian passion is because the
Christian passion is an archetypal story
because Christ is the person who
sacrifices everything
everything thoroughly 100% And the
biblical notion is that there's no
difference between that and the Descent
of the god of the Old Testament
into into into the space of human
reality
so God is elaborated as a spirit in the
Old Testament that's way of thinking
about it fleshed out right into the law
and the prophets and Christ presents
himself as the ENT of that so imagine
here's a way of thinking about it you
can invite various spirits to possess
you that's what you do when you give way
to Rage that's what you do when you give
way to lust let's say you allow spirits
to possess you well what would you be
like if you did nothing but allow the
highest of spirits to possess you well
that's the question that's put forth in
the New Testament and part of the answer
to that
is if you allowed the highest of all
possible spirits to possess you you
would be able to confront everything
that life could possibly throw at you
and that's what happens in the Christian
passion because the worst that life can
throw at you is the worst tragedy and
the worst tragedy is the worst death the
worst and most painful death inflicted
on the least deserving person right
that's the ultimate reach of tragedy
okay that's not enough Christ has to
confront that and he has to confront
malevolence that's the harrowing of hell
so the idea is that to adapt fully to
life you have to allow yourself to be
possessed by the spirit that will enable
you to voluntarily face unjust suffering
and death and evil it's like well you
got an argument against that how could
it be any other way one of the things
that I think I see people respond to
this degree of pray pressure when they
think
about what is going to happen long term
uh I have discomfort that is in front of
me now that I need to face that I need
to go through if I'm going to get to
Something in the future that I think
that I'm supposed to do and one of the
solutions that they come up with which
isn't the solution but it kind of is to
them is I'm not going to do anything
yeah you know that uh no decision is
kind of the same as a neutral a neutral
Choice one of my friends Alex has got
this quote which I love and says the
heaviest things in life aren't iron and
gold but unmade decisions the reason you
are stressed is that you have decisions
to make and you're not making them yeah
yeah that's yeah yeah no doubt about it
well there's no
indecision right there's
only because you
age like you pay for your you pay for
your indecision it's a decision it's a
decision to avoid fundament mentally
know and part of the moral that's
embedded in the story of Job And in the
Christian passion is that you can Master
what you'll
face and maybe that's true maybe that's
true I mean the clinical literature
seems to indicate that it's true because
one of the things you do if you're
a competent
clinician is you look at what people are
attempting to accomplish and and maybe
that needs some retooling but let's
assume that they have a goal in mind
that would work right you've talked it
through with them strategically they
have a well-laid out Vision okay now
they're laying out the vision and they
encounter impediments that stop them and
maybe they're impediments that make them
afraid and paralyze them and so then
what you do is
you decompose the impediment just as we
talked about earlier until you find a
way they can advance
that constitutes a genuine advance that
they'll actually do so what you do is
you take the problem and you narrow it
until they'll face it okay then they
face it then what happens they get more
competent that's what happens and then
they get better at facing all problems
so they don't just learn how to deal
with that specific problem they learn a
lesson that generalizes across problems
they get braver when you do when you use
exposure therapy people don't get less
afraid they get braver
that's way better because braver braver
moves from situation to situation okay
so the question is here here's the
question if you faced everything that
was put in front of you who would you be
well the answer the biblical answer is
you'd be a true Son of God that's the
biblical answer it's like well do you
believe that well it depends on what you
mean by
believe do you think that you do you
have a better bet than facing what's
there there well you just have to be
sensible about it for a moment it's like
is your theory that you're going to
adapt better using falsehood and
avoidance because that's the contrary
Theory you either face
it and you do that predicated on the
faith that something in you will respond
if you do or you don't face it those
that's it those are the options if you
don't face it that's Faith too that's
faith in the notion that of avoidance
and deception
will suffice I think that for a lot of
people it's it's born out of fear it's
born out of being a people pleaser yeah
and not wanting to hurt other people
around you and not wanting to tell them
things that they don't want to hear or
not doing or saying things that you know
are going to upset the people that are
around you right but in the short term
again yeah in the short term again you
know if if you look at a good mother a
good mother upsets her kids a lot quit
doing that why well why
why not just let your children do
exactly what they want when the answer
to that is well first of all it
terrifies them because kids actually
want they want walls they don't want to
be in the desert doing anything they
want they want a walled space in which
they have the optimal amount of Freedom
so a person who truly loves someone else
doesn't strive at all cost never to
upset them that's that's the devouring
mother if if you love someone well
that's the Biblical quote you chastise
them well what does it mean it's like
look if you love someone and they're
doing something stupid and
self-destructive and you can see it it's
incumbent on you to say you know this is
going to upset you but as far as I can
tell you're doing something stupid and
self-destructive and then there's going
to be a tussle about that because
they're going to say well who are you to
judge and that's a perfectly good
question is what makes you think you're
right and here's the reasons I'm doing
this and you know these are the terrible
experiences that I've had that have led
me to take this path and sometimes that
can be really compelling you know you
meet people who are bitter and resentful
and then they tell you about their life
and you think well yeah
but but then you meet people who've had
just as terrible a life who aren't
bitter and resentful right and they're
doing better and so even if it seems
justifiable maybe even if it is
justifiable it's not justifiable one of
the most common situations I think that
this people pleasing tendency would show
up in is someone who maybe thinks that
they should break up with a relationship
but doesn't do it and sticks about in
order to protect their partner and I
found a thread on Reddit that was five
questions to ask yourself if you're
unsure about your
relationship if someone told you you're
a lot like your partner would this be a
compliment to you are you truly
fulfilled or just less lonely are you
able to be unap netically yourself or do
you feel the need to show up differently
to please your partner are you in love
with who your partner is right now as a
whole or are you only in love with their
good side their potential or the idea of
them and would you want your future or
imagined child to date someone like your
partner and this thread was just filled
with people having existential crisis
and it seemed to me to
be a collection of people who had
managed to believe that continuing to
Manana Manana the short-term MH
postponement of the discomfort of the
decision that they wanted to have around
their partner uh was somehow the noble
thing to do or the good thing to do or
The Virtuous thing to do or the thing
that ultimately would result in the best
outcome even though they knew that if
they spread it out long enough and then
it's just hidden would just shoven under
the rug so yeah that uh list of five
questions I think uh well in most
relationships you can break up or you
can have a thousand
fights you know and if you have a
thousand fights then you don't have to
fight you make peace that way you know
because you're different than your
partner so there's things to work out
there and you might think about that as
a compromise but it's not it's
that you're different than your partner
and you have to find a game that you
both want to play that's not a
compromise that's a solution it's like
you bring your skills to the table and I
bring my skills to the table and then we
figure out some game we can play where
we're both optimally utilized and it's a
better game than we could play alone
that's not a compromise well but getting
to that very difficult and people bring
all sorts of baggage to a relationship
and you have to it's just like
disciplining children really it's the
same thing your children are you note
your children are annoying you you can
note that oh they I'm being annoyed by
my child okay so what questions do you
ask am I a tyranical son of a [__]
who's touchy well that's why you need
your wife cuz you can go ask her my kids
are annoying am I a tyrannical son of a
[__] who's touchy and she said yeah you
probably need something to eat or you're
a bit of a prick that way and you got to
listen because maybe it's you or maybe
she says yeah that goddamn child's been
getting on my case too and then you ask
each other are we mutually tyrants it's
like no that kid's annoying okay do we
want him to be
annoying well if you love your child
then the answer to that would be no CU
if he's annoying you he's going to annoy
other people he's annoy his potential
friends he's going to annoy other adults
he's going to go through the world being
annoying and everyone's going to frown
at him that's not helpful so then you
could just fix it and you're that's
going to cause some short-term upset you
know you're maybe you have a like a
13-month-old child who's very
extroverted and disagreeable who like
rules the roost and every time the
mother goes more than a foot away from
her she has a squawk fit because she's
learned to control maybe the mother you
know was still tied up with infant care
and can't put down a boundary and so now
you have to do something about this
emerging monster of a 14-month-old child
and one of the things you do is every
time the child is bossy first of all you
not it and you knowe that you're not
very fond of yourself for being
tyrannized by a 14-month-old that's a
bit of a status hit like it should be so
you have to notice I'm annoyed by this
child then I should do something about
it Well's going to cost short-term
emotional distress the same thing occurs
when you're dealing with your partner
it's like you're annoying me okay now
maybe that's me so I should bloody well
maybe we should have a talk about that
you're annoying me convince me that it's
me and I should listen because maybe
it's me and if I'm annoyed about you and
I shouldn't be I should fix that but
maybe it's you so let's find out exactly
what's going on you know and that'll
usually man that's that's there's just
constant thrust and counter thrust in a
discussion like that and usually you
know the conversation will circle around
whatever the hell the issue is till you
get to the bottom of it and God only
knows where that is but then maybe you
can sort it out you know and if you sort
out enough of those things you live in
peace and that's something worth
attaining you know and I've thought
forever in my marriage there's nothing
there's nothing too small to fight about
now you know I put in some rules that I
used to have with my clients to it's
like if someone bugs you you should note
that and you shouldn't do anything about
it probably if they bug you twice the
same way then you think oh okay that's
twice but probably still you shouldn't
do anything about it but if they bug you
three times then you can
say here's what you just did and they'll
say well no I didn't do that and then
you say yeah you did and you did exactly
the same thing in this other situation
and you did exactly the same thing in
this other situation so don't be telling
me you didn't do it cuz you did it three
times and I watched okay now they come
up with reasons they did it and maybe
some of them have to do with what a
stupid son of a [__] you are and you
should listen because maybe they're
right but that's at least the beginnings
of the process by which you unravel the
problems you want to figure out well we
don't want to do this this isn't the way
we want to treat each other we want to
get to a place
where
we want to get to a place where our
whole life is like the best moments of
the best dates we ever
had that's a good goal and that's that's
that's
attainable it you got to work man
there's there's a the scene in the in
Genesis God throws Adam and Eve out of
paradise because of their pride their
sin of
Pride they each have their own
particular version of that sin Eve's sin
and Adam's but they get thrown out of
paradise anyways for pride and God puts
cherubs at the gates of paradise and the
cherubs they're kind of these monstrous
Angels terrifying figures and they hold
swords that are on fire that turn Every
Witch Way and burn and you might say
well what does that mean and it means
that well a sword is something that cuts
away right a sharp blade and a and fire
is something that Burns and a sword that
Burns Burns and cuts away and a sword
that burns and
turns every which way is a burning sword
from which nothing can
escape okay now you want to walk into
Paradise everything that isn't worthy in
you has to be burned and cut away right
well that's what that conflict is in a
relationship you know it's like that's
not suitable for Paradise what does it
have to to do it has to be cast into the
outer Darkness where there will be
nashing of teeth right it has to be cut
away and destroyed and everything that
isn't worthy has to go well the
Michelangelo effect is all about you and
your partner becoming the idealized
version of each other right you are
going to do for me the things that I
want within your parameters of control
that you want to be the best partner for
me and I want to do the same for you and
we're both going to communicate to each
other and we're going to stand our
ground where we have boundaries and
we're going to continue to compromise
that's what love should do that's what
love should do like if you love
someone if it's genuine love you
see you see their hidden Soul that's a
good way of thinking about it you get a
glimpse of the light that they could
reveal to the world if they revealed it
that's what you see and then to act in
love is to encourage that to come
forward and to discourage anything that
gets in its way that's why I love the
the Michelangelo effect I'd heard of and
I'd been using it okay so why the
Michelangelo effect this is why
Michelangelo sees this huge massive UNH
block Mar I see I see and inside of that
he is able to see David MH and over time
slowly he will chip away and he will
chip away and he will chip away so you
see something that isn't there that's
inside of the thing which is rough and
UNH Hune and uncivilized and
undomesticated and rambunctious and and
sometimes terrible
and you were able to from that yeah
that's actually part of the
ding the uncarved block so a child is an
uncarved Block in in in the dowst view
and and you remove everything that's
excess until what's perfect remains
right and that's see the the logos in
the Old and New Testament the logos that
creates the world is the judging faculty
that
what would you say that separates the
wheat from the
chaff right and it's not it's compassion
in a sense because if you're
compassionate towards someone you want
what's best for them all things
considered but that compassion in the
highest sense can't exist without
judgment because the judgment is this
part of you isn't worthy to continue and
certainly that's what you're doing with
your children when you see them
misbehaving you think no that's no not
that that not that something more
sophisticated even with my little
granddaughter the other day she's very
very playful and she's a very nice
little girl she's very playful and very
fun and funny and not neurotic and so
she's a pleasure to be around but she
hasn't seen me for a while and so she
was poking me getting me to chase her
around and poking me and she'd come up
and give me a whack you know and at one
point she whacked me too hard and she
knew it and I said that's not fun that's
not acceptable and then she started but
she was playing with that edge trying to
find out where fun is and you know can
how hard can I hit Grandpa she does
bloody well know she kind of knows but
she needs to know exactly well I can't
let her get away with it because then
she's not fun to play with she has to
learn to come and give her Grandpa a
whack in exactly the way that elicits a
playful response and that isn't annoying
and so there's a very you know you might
think well it's pretty harsh judgment to
lay on a 5-year-old it's like no it's
not I would like her to be the most fun
kid to play with that she could be right
and so I'm not going to pretend that
it's okay when it's not not setting that
boundary is almost like a curse it is a
curse yeah there you go away we were
yeah because then how's she going to
play with other with other kids if she
doesn't know they're going to be as
forgiving as Grandpa definitely not yeah
we were talking before we got started I
had this conversation with Robert
spolski and it it was really really
profound I mean I know that he's a
brilliant guy and this new book of his
is about sort of Free Will and deter
fism which has got an upper bound on how
interesting that is for me but he gave
this quote to Andrew hubman where he
said dopamine is not about the pursuit
of happiness it is about the happiness
of pursuit right that's definitely right
and I I haven't been able to stop seeing
this everywhere so uh Morgan housel um a
friend told me this great story uh he is
an investor he's got a fund he's an
author he's got a family he got all of
these things they plan to go away on
holiday and they've been planning it for
a long time time and with the kids and
the wife and him and all of his
businesses it was a arduous thing to go
through to get themselves out there and
finally they get there after the journey
and the plane and the children and the
crying and all the rest of it and he
walks out on the balcony on the first
night of this holiday that they've
planned for forever and his first
thought to himself
was wouldn't it be great if we came back
here next year it would be so great if
we could come back here next year so
literally during the supposed enjoyment
of the destination he was already
thinking about the journey and you know
it's not the joury it's not the
destination it's the journey is kind of
TR but it it puts a new perspective on
it there is no destination each
destination is simply the beginning of
the next journey and I haven't not been
I haven't not been able to see it I see
it I see it everywhere I see it
everywhere in my own life well there's
there's technically two different forms
of reward there's consumatory reward and
so that's the reward that's what an
orgasm is it's consummatory reward it's
it it brings the behavioral and
perceptual sequence to a halt it ends it
right at the climax it ends it but then
it's over that journey is over right
then there's the dopaminergic reward
that spolski was talking about and
dopaminergic reward is evidence of
advancement towards a goal right okay so
so there's a corollary to
that well how do you become optimally
engaged because dopamine facilitates Eng
engagement and focus which is why drugs
like amphetamines can be used for kids
who
are attention deficit disordered you T
tap up the dopamine response they lock
on right okay so they're locking on to a
goal directed Pursuit the problem with
amphetamines is that they can lock you
on so hard you can't get out of the
frame so like kids on amphetamines will
obsess for example about cleaning up
their closet they can't switch to the
next activity okay dopaminergic reward
is reward that's accured in relationship
to a goal okay so what what's an
implication of that well pursue the
highest possible goal well why because
the kick from advancement is higher now
you have to balance that it can't be you
have to advance right because imagine
the rewards got two components number
one is you're moving towards something
valuable okay so you want it to be as
valuable as possible okay but you have
to be moving so it can't be so valuable
that it's out of your reach you're going
to walk to the Moon I'm not going to be
able to see every single increment that
I make yes you want to get to the moon
that's right you can't walk there so
it's a bad plan you need something
extremely valuable that you can move
towards okay so part of the reason that
you establish a relationship with God
let's say is because that's what sets
the upper bound to your vision it's like
I want things to be the best they could
be that's a vision of paradise well that
has to be fractionated into you know
your proximal decisions but lurking
behind that should be this continual
movement towards what would you say a
heaven that recedes as you approach it
that's the proper vision of Heaven A
Heaven is a place that's perfect and
getting
better both at the same time that's what
music shows you because a great piece of
music is perfect but it's just getting
better as it unfolds and and you need
that this is part of the problem with a
static utopian Vision something dovi
criticized if you gave people Nothing
But consumatory reward he famously says
so that they can do nothing but sit in
tubs of hot water eat cake and busy
themselves with the with the
continuation of the species human beings
would break that all to Hell in a moment
just so they have something interesting
to do what was that quote that you said
on Rogan years
ago if we were to make the sufficiently
perfect the only desired lack would be
for the desire of lack itself what's
that kard what's the what's the proper
can you remember well kard pointed out
that if we if as we make the world
easier and easier so this is perhaps
part of the problem with the material
plenty that's at hand is that at some
point what becomes lacking is lack
itself yes right yes exactly exactly
it's optimal deprivation you know and if
everything is delivered to you on a
platter it's like what the hell are you
even doing there this happens in the
story of
Abraham so Abraham who's the father of
Nations right so Abraham gets it right
he has everything at the beginning of
the story he has Rich parents he has
he's he's got nothing that he has to do
he's like 70 when the story opens he's
been taken care of hand in foot his
whole life and the voice of God comes to
him and says I'm the god of your
ancestors telling you get out of your
zone of comfort get out into the world
and Abraham's pretty old by this point
but for whatever reason he decides that
he's going to forgo the comfort for the
adventure and then as Abraham progresses
he makes the requisite sacrifices each
becoming more difficult as he ascends
and he adopts this pattern of
relationship with the god that calls him
to Adventure that literally makes him
the father of Nations and so you can can
even think about that biologically if
you want you might as well people like
Dawkins think reproduction is
sex and that's why he can talk for
example about the selfish Gene making
itself manifest in sex reproduction
isn't
sex sex is a necessary but insufficient
precondition for
reproduction Abraham adopts a motive
being a sacrificial motive being that
establishes the optimal environment for
his sons who then established the
optimal environment for their sons and
their sons and their sons so you can
imagine that what Abraham is doing this
is what the story means is he's adopting
a mode of behavior that works best All
Things Considered across multiple
generations and he sacrifices everything
to that it's this incredibly expansive
Vision given that we're in a world which
is comfortable
and we we have created buildings in
which there are heavy things that you
pick up and put down in the same place
because it's simply so rare that you
have to pick up heavy things right the
bumps on our roads for the same reason
proliferation of ice baths and sauna and
and and and even reading to some extent
you know difficult reading difficult
things where should people go given that
they are in a a world which is more
comfortable than ever before where
should they go to encourage them to find
difficult things
truth truth is what's optimally
difficult the truth is optimally
difficult that's a really wonderful
thing to know the truth is Adventure
there's no there's no distinction partly
because if you're going to just say what
you believe to be true you have to let
go of the consequences you can't predict
the
consequences well there's no difference
between not being able to predict the
consequences and having an adventure
they're the same thing right because if
you knew the consequences it wouldn't be
an adventure it's not an adventure if if
the if the consequences are forgone the
same as it's no sacrifice or courage if
there's no risk right right right it's
exactly the same and so it's a it's a
wonderful thing to know that optimized
Adventure is to be had in the truth
think in every given situation so Christ
says in The Sermon on the Mount that to
orient yourself properly and it's often
viewed as this hippie pay on take no
thought of the moral the moral will take
care of itself you know God takes care
of The Sparrows he'll certainly take
care of you it's like a hippie wet dream
it isn't what that isn't the that isn't
the core of the message the the core of
the message is very straightforward
Christ says aim up to the highest thing
you can possibly imagine so that's the
relationship with God you put what's at
the Pinnacle properly at the Pinnacle
and you aim at at that and
then you
concentrate that and it's that and
treating other people like you would
like to be treated yourself that sets
the moral frame then you attend to the
day and the cares of the day it's like
once you've established the proper moral
frame you pay attention to the day and
you live in truth and that moves you
towards that destination you have to
have the orientation right you have to
be aiming up but then it's just a matter
of
what would you say abiding by the truth
that's the logos that sets people free
and that's right doing it properly right
there was one of the other rules that
didn't make it into your book uh nothing
Well Done is insignificant right right
right right yeah well you acrew so
Christ tells his followers in the
gospels to to store up treasure in
heaven not in the places that moths can
eat and rust can destroy well what is
that what is meant by that well it's
meant by the same it means the same
thing that you just pointed to which is
that if you run yourself through a
disciplin disciplinary process so you
accomplish something maybe it doesn't
you don't attain the goal you were
aiming at but you acrw a new way of
looking at the world in a set of skills
well if you just keep doing that you
have multiple ways of looking at the
world in more and more skill well that's
that's your Storehouse of treasure you
know the reason women use wealth as a
proxy for attractiveness is because
wealth is a proxy for competence it's
not competence because you can be rich
and useless now it's not that easy but
it can at least happen temporarily but
women use markers of wealth to assess
competence and the competence is the
treasure not the wealth because if
you're competent you could be thrown
into the desert and you'll make it Bloom
I've said this about uh people that go
to the gym so from the outside someone
that goes to the gym and has got a good
body all whatever this the body and it
this is what you get to touch during sex
when you're intimate right but the story
that someone who has a good body tells
you about the sort of person that they
are is much more important I think than
the way that it manifests physically
it's someone who is reliable who is able
to overcome hard things who is self
disciplined it's just this whole big
long laundry list of things that they're
able to uh deal with pain and discomfort
which is kind of sexy in a way
uh perfect it's the perfect materialist
disciplinary strategy right because it's
very concrete well you change your body
it's like is that a spiritual Pursuit
well it is in so far as it requires you
know long-term discipline and and
sacrifice and you might hope and I think
this is likely the case that you know
you can get stuck in the bodily
self-improvement Niche and and focus on
that too obsessively but you can also
use it as a stepping stone to discipline
Pursuit itself and lots of people do
that I think I told you the last time
that we chatted about the Mano pause
this thing that I'd come up with so I
noticed toward the end of my 20s that
lots of guys who had been training with
a particular modality usually
bodybuilding usually exclusively for the
way that they looked realized as they
approached their 30s that they were
getting out of breath going up a set of
stairs and that they maybe couldn't
touch their toes and they looked
fantastic but I don't know they they
just felt like they should maybe start
to Value different things and then
changed their training and they would go
and do Brazilian jiu-jitsu or yoga or
CrossFit or you know some other form of
whatever and that precipitated a change
in everything else and I saw this in
myself right I get toward the end of my
20s I've achieved success in many of the
ways that Society tells a young man that
he should value success there was a
discordance something fell off and you
then think okay
well maybe I need to assess whether or
not the things that I've been being told
I should want are things that I actually
want to want and very quickly you
realize I don't know it feels like a
quarter life crisis I think so many men
go through this they go I either
succeeded or didn't succeed at a game
that I was told that I was supposed to
Value playing and upon reflection I
really don't care for it as much as I
thought I did maybe there was some
elements I was so proud of what i' done
with my business partners I was so proud
of the things that we'd achieved but
then there was other stuff where I was
like why have I attached so much of my
sense of selfworth into this and and
this and then you start you have to
assess and the so this is what happens
in the story of Exodus when Moses and
encounters the burning
bush so he's just going about his
business as a shepherd and he's doing
all right he's got two wives he likes
his father-in-law he's well regarded in
this new country that he's in he's left
Egypt where there's a price on his head
essentially for killing a Egyptian who
was Tor tormenting a uh one of the
Hebrews anyways Moses is just going
about his business as a Shepherd which
was a very tough job in those days and
this thing catches his eye this this
glimmer this gleam and he goes to
investigate okay so what what does that
mean it means as you're progressing
through life something will capture your
interest and in the story you just told
it's like somebody decides they're going
to start going to the gym there's
something about becoming physically fit
that calls to them right which is an
interesting thing right because it calls
to them it's not even necessarily a
decision they make it's more like a
possibility that makes itself manifest
that's of Interest so they decide to
pursue it so they look into it more
deeply well so Moses approaches the
burning bush and he gets closer and
closer right and a bush is a symbol of
life right like it's a tree a tree of
life and a tree of life that's on fire
is being that's the life the tree and
becoming that's the fire the
transformation so a burning bush is a
symbol of being and becoming as such now
it's something that beckons okay okay so
now you pursue your physical fitness CU
it's called to you and you concentrate
more and more on it you get more and
more discipline but as you get more and
more discipline you start to transform
right and so your vision starts to
change now what happens to Moses is that
as he gets closer and closer to the
burning bush he starts to realize that
he's on sacred ground so he's going
deeper the investigation is taking him
deeper so he takes off his shoes and and
continues to approach he's still going
down the same Trail right pursuing this
thing and then the voice of God itself
speaks to him from the midst of the
burning bush and that's what turns him
into a leader and so what does the story
mean it means that as you walk through
life in your normal mode things will
call to you and if you pursue them they
will take you deep it doesn't really
matter what it is that calls what
matters is that you pursue it and you
you pursue it to the depths and as you
pursue it to the depths you will become
transformed and if you do that without
reserv a that will turn you into that
will turn you into the person who frees
the slaves and opposes the tyrants and
that is how it works that's the call and
that can happen in any direction
virtually any
direction you just have to pursue it
with sufficient Faith
right one of the things that's been I
guess derogated a lot by pretty much
everybody uh at the moment is University
education
and I had such an interesting time at
University almost exclusively outside of
my education right all of the good
things that happened to me while I spent
5 years at
Newcastle didn't include what I was
taught it was never inside of the
lecture theater it was everything I was
doing outside of that and lots of my
friends it's very trendy on the internet
to mock higher education as useless
pieces of paper uh it's not you don't
need it in order to be able to be
successful certainly the thing that I've
ended up doing this podcast didn't
require me to go to university maybe in
some ways it did but also from a
definitely from a qualification
perspective it didn't but I I think I'm
still relatively Pro University
experience uh and yeah you know you've
got Peterson Academy launching which is
your new thing I wondered how you
thought well basically are universi
salvageable given that so much that's
good about the university experience has
almost nothing to do with the education
side of
it are they
salvageable some are I
imagine um
Hillsdale does great what's that it's a
conservative College in northeastern us
run by Larry AR they have a 1% dropout
rate as opposed to the typical 50%
dropout rate and they they provide a
classic
IAL what used to be a liberal education
liberal arts education it's a more
conservative Enterprise given how the
Overton window has shifted but
Larry's students concentrate on physical
fitness his philosophy Department tends
to meet in the weight room which is
pretty interesting he has weight benches
scattered all around the campus about a
third of the students take music courses
so the place is very musical um it's a
very disciplined place the quality of
education is extremely high so there are
institutes that are holding to their
mandate I think that's rare and I think
overall the universities have become
irretrievably corrupt as far as I can
tell and
so
we had hoped that we could provide
something approximating an alternative
but you put your finger on one of the
complexities in doing doing that it's
easy to think that a university is the
transmission of Knowledge from experts
to empty vessels the students let's say
so it's lectures tests and accreditation
but that's not really what a university
is it's an apprenticeship if you're
fortunate when you go to university you
find a professor or two that you can
work with who really teach you how to
think they're usually those professors
are gen generally quite rare and you're
fortunate if you do establish a
relationship that like that especially
at a big university where the student to
faculty ratio is absurdly high like 200
to1 I was in lecture theaters that were
300 to1 yeah I didn't I didn't get a
relationship like that with any of my
right right and that's that's that's
really not good because you need you
need an apprenticeship relationship to
become educated fundamentally um we
started this we're formulating Peterson
Academy we're hoping that we can provide
people with extremely highquality
lectures I'm fortunate as you are to be
able to reach out to people who are
charismatic and well educated and we
offer them a good Financial deal and we
treat them very well and they come down
to Miami and they record a relatively
short lecture series eight hours and
uh we're implementing state-of-the-art
testing procedures and we're going to be
giving out a certificate that you will
have to earn to acquire and so we're
hoping that the quality of our graduates
will be such that the certificate will
speak to for itself as a marker for
conscientiousness and educated expertise
we'll see we're also building out the
social side of it because as you pointed
out a huge part of what happens to you
when you go to university is social and
socialization
you get to make a whole new group of
friends it's a big deal right it's a
huge it's one of those times in your
life where you
can parcel off who you were and you can
become something new well you remember
every single summer at least for me
maybe this is because I was chronically
so unpopular in school I would come back
every summer uh imagining that I would
be able to reinvent myself I'm going to
be the cool kid this year I'm going to
be the sporty kid this here or whatever
whatever but the big one is a because
you're not even in the same town no one
even knows who you are no one even knows
what to think about who you are right
and uh yeah that for me was the big
inflection point of me going from the
child that I was to the sort of young
adult that I was going to end up right
right well if you're fortunate you have
a number of times where that happens in
your life where you can make a
relatively clean break and you can
Invent Yourself a new right this just to
interject that like
y there's an idea called monk mode uh
which has kind of become a bit of of a
meme online but I first read about this
years ago uh and it involves a extended
period of um isolation to work on
yourself uh to reflect on your flaws to
kind of do the inner work to introspect
um it's
usually tied in with meditation with
improving your diet with improving your
physical fitness your mental Fitness all
of these different things and uh
that I've almost seen it as if doing
that and focusing on yourself for a
short space of time that's very very you
know it's maybe a couple of months
really really focusing on you still
going about and doing your work and
doing the rest of the things but outside
of that just really really trying to
make yourself as good as possible
periodizing that for me was one of the
most powerful inflections aside from the
lifestyle change and well that's what
confession is supposed to be
fundamentally I mean when you take stock
of yourself you
confess you confess to yourself
and you make your sins a
reality you assess yourself for your
insufficiency and you Proclaim your
insufficiencies and that well then you
can start working on them it's like it's
painful here's all the things that I'm
not here's all the things that I'm not
that I would like to be right that's
painful self-examination but the
advantage is you get all your problems
on the table
and the advantage to that is that
problem by
problem there's likely some hope like
for example you said you were unpopular
when you were a teenager but that
doesn't mean that you had to carry that
forward into University right there was
a possibility that so how did you get
out of that what did you
do the main reason I think was that I
didn't really understand how to relate
to other kids so I found myself
obsessing over the way that other kids
would wear their shirts or tie their
ties or the sort of shoes that they
would wear or the right so you were
looking at external models or yeah and
that's why that's why they had friends
and I didn't right and I didn't realize
that it was just I
wasn't socially Adept I didn't
understand how to relate to other kids
very well and I think I just got to the
stage especially when I went to
University that I'd spent enough time
for me to have learned at least some
rough HED social skills and now finally
was able to sort of cast off some of the
uh presuppositions that uh had maybe
been following me uh because what were
the opening points for you like do you
remember the first friendship you made
in University oh yeah the guys that I
lived with so okay so these were these
were roommates yeah yeah yeah okay so
yeah that's a good op see that's a thing
that's hard to duplicate online right
because it's a having
a group of Roommates is a
formative experience it was crazy for me
I didn't know because again only child
two parents living in a small house I
didn't know that you were supposed to
knock on someone's bedroom door before
you were to go in I'd never done that
I'd spent my did 18 years I'd never had
to knock on anybody's bedroom door CU
like Mom and Dad are down like who else
is there I'm going to knock on the dogs
like a kitchen door to see if the dogs
would mind me going into the kitchen uh
and so many of those things looking back
at it now are just so ridiculous not
knowing that that was something that you
was supposed to do yeah well not knowing
those Elementary skills though that can
be a huge impediment you know I had
people in my clinical practice we spend
hours practicing how to introduce them
and to shake hands because you want to
be expert at that because if you're not
good at that at all like if you're
really bad at it you're
screwed you can't even tell someone your
name and so how are you going to make a
friend then you you you announce
yourself as incompetent with your first
move and then if you do if that happens
to you 10 times you're so terrified
disincentivizes oh God terribly terribly
and so you should become expert at that
that's something you can do with your
kids is so they can become expert at
introducing themselves you know shake
hands do it with a bit of a firm grip
look at the other person try smiling you
know match your Tempo to the other
person another Dynamic that I've been
thinking about recently I was at a
retreat in La a few months ago and one
of the guys that was there had said he'
stopped talking and writing on the
internet because he noticed that the
story he was telling in public he began
feeling the necessity to live up to in
private and I think that whether you're
a a writer or just someone that's got
500 followers on your Instagram and a
Facebook from back in the day or
whatever there is a there is an online
Persona that people put forward that
they then almost feel is more real than
what they are and then they try and
reverse engineer themselves to fit this
new is this well that's the problem with
writing essays that contain what your
professor wants to hear so you can't do
that without altering your soul you
can't do that you you cannot construct
for yourself a false Persona designed to
extract resources from the world without
that becoming part of you like there's
no one is that sophisticated no one can
have two selves like that this part of
the reason why you have to be very
careful about what you say and do is
that
you're when you when you practice
falsehood you become false it's not like
those are beliefs that are just in your
head you rewire yourself so you start to
literally see the world through the
frame of your falsehoods that's a very
bad plan I've heard you say if you say
things long enough you're going to
believe them you become them it's even
worse than believing them it's deeper
than that they they're built into as
unquestioned implicit axioms and as we
said earlier on this can go in either
direction right you can fake it until
you make it one small step at a time
moving toward a vision which you know is
positive and you continually reassess to
ensure that you're not getting hijacked
and going in the wrong direction yes or
or you generate a so look in the in the
Pinocchio movie which I've analyzed to
death in the Disney Pinocchio movie Mr
Pinocchio yeah yes world's leading
Pinocchio Sol so Pinocchio exactly
exactly part Pinocchio is trying to get
rid of the strings that that that pull
on him every which way that aren't under
his control and to become something
genuine okay so he has three basic
Temptations one
is to
lie right so that's the
nose the another is to be an actor and
when I first came across that in the
movie I thought what the hell's going on
here one of Pinocchio's Temptations is
to be an actor now why would the
Hollywood people do that why would they
denigrate the actor and then I thought
oh it's not an actor it's a false
Persona to be the actor instead of the
real thing to be the appearance instead
of the reality to take the credit
instead of doing the work right to be
false next temptation is to be neurotic
it's so interesting especially in in in
the world that we have now how
perspicacious these animators were
Pinocchio is literally enticed onto the
island of pleasure by a false Doctor Who
diagnoses him with an illness he doesn't
have and the the story is look how sick
you are you're working too hard you need
to go to Pleasure Island well Pleasure
Island is run by
slavers right so it's
perfect
well be careful what you practice be
careful what you practice right you can
be the actor of your own ideal and
that's a way of Step stepping forward
but when you make false claims to who
you are to gain status in consequence
you are you are perverting your soul
what's the soul the soul is something
like the structure through which the
world re reveals itself to you it's
something like that so you don't see
much of the world right you see it
through narrow apertures you see what
you allow in that's another way of
thinking about it you better make sure
it's the bright part of the world World
re revealing itself to you and that
isn't going to be the case if you lie
one of the problems I think that a lot
of the people listening to this podcast
and certainly a lot of my friends who
are smart and cerebral
encounter they think themselves into
problems and they struggle to use their
intuition because they are able to come
up with a reason about why they should
or should not at any moment you know
talking about the soul or the inner
voice or the conscience or you know you
might refer to it as God that's coming
through the best version of
yourself people that ruminate and
introspect are very capable of talking
themselves into or out of something that
feels like because they worship the
intellect how would you advise somebody
who enjoys thinking about things deeply
to cast that off and be able to hear
themselves a little bit more clearly
there's a difference between attention
and
intellect there's there's something to
be said for paying attention it's not
the same thing like the intellect let's
say the intellect produces thoughts the
attention gathers
information right so if
I'm well if I'm conducting a podcast
let's say I'm paying attention to what I
don't understand I'm not thinking it's
not the same thing I mean sometimes I
think because the person will say
something and'll set off a train of
thoughts but often what I'm just doing
is like well do I understand what you
just said that's a matter of attention I
have to note my ignorance I'm attending
to my ignorance well this is what
Rogan's great at this you're great at
this as well if you attend to your
ignorance then you know what to do you
just ask the question it's like well I
don't understand this that's a form of
humility to attend to your ignorance
that's a good thing for those who
worship the luciferian intellect to do
is to attend to their own ignorance it's
not about what you know it's about what
you don't know you already know what you
know so why not investigate what you
don't know well how do you do that you
attend to your
ignorance what's the definition of
humility humility is attending to your
ignorance and you can do that wherever
you are is that not still uh an
intellectual exercise here are the holes
in what I know therefore I'm just going
to continue ask to ask the questions
until I fill
them well it's not something completely
divorced
from it's the difference between
questioning and
answering like I would say this is let's
say definitional the luciferian
intellect has an answer what's when you
say luciferian intellect what's that the
luciferian intellect is the intellect
that wants to place itself in the
highest position and there's lots of
people smart people tend to be
luciferian because they think that their
fundamental value is their intelligence
and they think that intelligence is the
fundamental value and then they're often
very annoyed if they're very bright and
the world doesn't lay itself out at
their feet because they think well I'm
so smart everything should just be
coming my way because they've prided
themsel on that it's like and
intellectual Pride well that might be
the cardinal sin the luciferian
intellect is the intellect that wants to
put itself in the highest position it's
challenges God that's what Satan is
that's what Lucifer is literally in the
miltonian story is Lucifer is the spirit
who attempts to usurp God that's what
the Communists did that's what the
fascists did that's what we do when we
build towers of Babel and we can easily
Elevate the intellect to the highest
possible place especially smart people
they do that all the time it's better to
attend to what you don't know this is
why Rogan's a very good example of this
because Rogan is not an
intellectual he's a Seeker
those aren't the same thing Rogan is
always like a blood hound he's on the
path of what he doesn't know and the
consequence of that is he knows a lot
you know 2,000 podcasts 2 200 podcasts
he's done like 2500 highlevel graduate
seminars something like that it's crazy
and so his questions get better and
better as he fills in the gaps is it
intellectual no no it's not it's it's
it's there's a difference between an
intellectual Pursuit and a spiritual
Pursuit and the remediation of your own
ignorance is a spiritual Pursuit it's
predicated on humility how am I stupid
how can I fix that you know one of the
things I really taught my kids tried to
teach them was ask stupid
questions right and that means you have
to admit to your own insufficiency
that's what humility is and then you
have to publicly announce it here's how
I'm stupid can you fix me and you know
sometimes that is embarrassing although
much less frequently than people think
usually if you're in a crowd and you
have a stupid question and you've been
paying attention 80% of the crowd has
the same question and they're relieved
that you know you an you asked it in
fact they'll think you're brave it's so
interesting e because you're afraid when
you ask a question if you're in a
university seminar you're afraid that
what you're going to do is expose your
stupidity and
be what would you say shamed and what
happens is exactly the opposite is
everybody who's too cowardly to ask that
question now thinks that you're
courageous it's exactly the opposite of
what you think yeah that happens all the
time always in my graduate Seminars the
kids that
asked the most ignorant questions
assuming they were paying attention
because you can ask a stupid question
you know stupid question is you're I
don't know you're fiddling with your
phone and you and the class is just
covered something and you didn't notice
and you ask well you know clue in that's
not a real question that's just you're
just wasting people's time but if you're
genuinely
ignorant I never had a student who asked
a genuine question that I thought was a
stupid question never and I'd never
treat a student that way it's like no no
if
you're if you it's so cool too because
sometimes the stupidest
questions cut to the heart of the chase
in you know it's the kids who would ask
a really basic
question that also forced me to really
understand what I was
teaching and that's a reflection of
their humility it's that humility in the
pursuit
of humility in the pursuit of the ideal
that's not an intellectual exercise not
not not in the strict sense it's
definitely what generates knowledge
though that seems to be a good stepping
block to what earned wisdom as well
that's earned wisdom y yep earned wisdom
through humility right what have you got
coming up next what can people expect
from you over the next few months well
what I'm working on right now is I'm
going to finish this book hopefully by
the end of December it'll be published
in November but I'm going to go on tour
weirdly enough about the book probably
starting in January I'm going to do an
American tour and then I think I'm going
to go to Africa and to South America and
to Southeast Asia that's the plan and
and um I'm very excited about this new
book um I'm hoping it'll be the best
book that I've ever
written it's it's going to be more
difficult book than the last two were
but not as difficult as maps of meaning
which my first book yeah it's it's it's
more it's heavy it's it's deeper have
you been fighting with trying to make it
accessible no not really right i' I've
been I've been I've been just trying to
lay the argument out as clearly as I can
like and I think that'll do the trick
and I I I have to go over it again and
edit it and make sure that it's no more
obscure than is absolutely necessary no
I want to lay it out so that it's
comprehensible and I've had a lot of
success with the biblical Ventures that
I've already embarked on I did a series
on Genesis in 2017 which turned out to
be quite influential and then I just did
a seminar on Exodus with a group of
thinkers and I know there's a hunger
for analysis of deep stories
and I also have good people around me
that can help me grind my way through
the stories and understand them and so
I'm very much looking I've been having
quite a good time writing this book
actually it's very difficult to write
but it's been extremely exciting and
interesting
and I'm hoping you asked me earlier what
would I consider success with this
book I don't think that you'll be able
to read this book and understand it and
be
atheistic I think I can demolish the
atheistic argument
permanently and it's partly it's a weird
thing because it's not like all of a
sudden people are going to throw
themselves at the feet of God and
worship it's like it requires a
reconsideration of what we mean by
belief and I walk through some of it
it's like do you believe in the good
well there
the difference between believing in good
and believing in God is it's it's a very
narrow
difference now there are important
differences but it's still a narrow
difference and the thing is if you don't
believe in in good you're aimless and if
you're aimless you're hopeless and if
you're aimless and hopeless you're
anxious and fractionated and people
can't unite in their beliefs like the
the alternative is not good reversing
the enlightenment is no small
task well hopefully we can save the best
of the Enlightenment as well it's like
uh the uh cheston's fence of cheston's
fence like how many how many different
fences are in the field so to speak and
if we thr this one out and we're trying
to plug it back in but whichit it's
going back one of the things that's very
interesting and I think I think people
like Dawkins have started to realize
this and I know that people like Douglas
Murray and ion hery Eli and Neil
Ferguson have recognized this is that
with the death of God many other things
die things you don't expect and one of
the things that dies when God dies is
science and no one expected that how
so because science as a practice is a
religious practice it it's predicated on
religious axioms is it well you have to
believe that there's such a thing as
truth you have to believe that the truth
is understandable you have to believe
that understanding the truth is good
good you have to believe that there is
such a thing as good right so imagine to
be a scientist you have to imagine that
first of all that the world is
comprehensible to the human intellect
but more that if you investigate the
mysteries of the material world that
that will be beneficial right those
aren't scientific claims those are
metaphysical
claims and that metaphysical claim is
nested in a
story you know and the the enlightenment
types they've portrayed the Scientific
Revolution as something contrary to the
religious substrate and that's not
accurate that's a French Revolution
that's a luciferian intellect history
it's not true the universities grew out
of the
monasteries that's where the
universities came from and science as a
widespread Enterprise got its start in
the universities and they grow out to
the monasteries that's not
questionable like if you go to Harvard
or if you go to Oxford and Cambridge
it's just starkly evident the layout of
the of the colleges is a monastic layout
so the idea
that there's some fundamental
contradiction between religious belief
and the scientific
Enterprise it's it's there's nothing
about that that's true and part of the
reason that we're Lo part of the reason
that we're losing the scientific
Enterprise right now is because we've
unmowed it from its metaphysical
substrate and it can't survive if you're
if you're going to be a scientist you
have to put the truth Above All Else
scientists are very rare you have to
believe in the truth to be a scientist I
think Dawkin believes in the truth by
the way so he's an atheist but a
very he's much less of an atheist than
he thinks that's my
impression lying scientists are
atheistic or just malevolent Dawkins is
a truthful scientist and in so far as
he's pursuing the truth and in so far as
he believes that pursuing the truth will
set you free then he's walking down a
path that's Christian to its core now I
know he doesn't like that idea but he
also doesn't like the fact that the
scientific Enterprise seems to be
collapsing in terms of its what would
you call reliability and validity
everywhere
so I appreciate you mate I appreciate
the time that we get to spend it always
seems to be a very interesting
inflection uh again this time yeah the
inflection this time is you're out on t
I am what's your advice for me how am I
going to survive life on the
road make sure that when you step on the
stage that you understand how unlikely
it is that you have the privilege to do
this and make sure you remember that all
those people who came to see you they're
hoping for something from you they put
in some time and energy to come and see
you it matters what you do you go out on
that stage with gratitude right that'll
help a lot you got to remember that it
keeps you on the ground too you should
be great ful that they're not throwing
rocks at you right how ridiculous is it
that you get to do this how unlikely is
it right exactly so you keep that first
and foremost in your mind you remember
that you should be stunningly grateful
for the miracle that you have the
opportunity to do this because it's
ridiculously
improbable yeah yeah trying to do that
without getting overwhelmed is becoming
an increasingly difficult task yeah well
part of the way you handle that is that
you parse off the jobs that other people
can do you know when you're out on tour
the social element of that can be
overwhelming so you have to protect
yourself from that to some degree but
the other thing you do is anything
anyone else can do get someone to do Ese
and get someone competent and reliable
so that all you're focusing on get to
the next show on time in the right frame
of mind that's your
job other people have their jobs make
sure you surrounded by people who do
their jobs like our tour so far they've
be become increasingly well-run I don't
worry about travel hotels meals
Transportation none of that I worry
about getting to the venue 1 hour ahead
of
time getting my head in the right place
which has to do with this attitude of
gratefulness that I described and then
trying to address a serious problem with
all the people who are participating in
the audience
and
then if it's too
much then distribute the responsibility
some more how do you wind down after a
show I watched the Trailer Park
Boys of course you do yeah yeah well
after being that good you have to not be
so good for a while and the Trailer Park
Boys is a very good way of doing that
counteracted a little bit Yeah I uh I
texted Rogan about this yesterday and I
thought that he would have you know God
knows how many shows that guy's done I
thought he would have some wisdom for me
I said every time that I do a show I um
I'm so excited after I finished that I
find it difficult to kind of wind down
and I've got four shows back to back
then we fly to Dubai then we've got all
these shows around the US and Canada and
uh I'm nervous that I'm not going to be
able to sleep and then if I don't sleep
then I'm not going to be able to perform
as well tomorrow and then it'll spiral
uh and I thought that he would just have
some wisdom and he said that's a tough
one man to be honest I've never had any
problem sleeping I well [__] that I
guess you know uh but no I'm excited I'm
excited and I'll check back in with you
once uh once everything's done we're
going to record one of them properly
fully properly record it uh like a
special um so that'll be maybe we'll put
it up maybe it'll just stay for
posterity I don't know but uh we're
going to have it so yeah I'm excited
yeah well good luck thank you man good
Lu should be a blast yeah yeah yeah I'm
definitely going to learn a lot and as
we've said today pushing through
discomfort and doing different things uh
and following something close to
Instinct a lot of the things that I'm
saying are
uh like vulnerable in some regards I
guess you know they things that are
meaningful to me uh and yeah I hope that
people take take a lot away from it and
I hope they have done from today too so
one of the things I do when I go on
stage is like I spend the first 10 or 15
seconds looking at the audience like I
don't mean would I've seen you do this a
lot I would I would technically refer to
it as
stalking um but it's not far from a St
it's it's it's good I I look everywhere
and this is a exposure technique Tech
you don't want to be afraid of the
audience and so at all and you don't
want to be talking to the audience so I
look at people and I see you know I I
look everywhere and as you know you
can't see in the back rows if it's a big
place but fundamentally I look
everywhere I can and I look at
individuals and I'm marking them out as
people and then I'm remembering you know
I'm talking to all these individual
people who've come here and then that's
easy because you can talk to individuals
and they're your guests say that's
another that's another thing for your
staff to know too it's like everyone who
comes to one of your events has to be
treated in the most positive possible
way cuz they're looking to you for
something you know and it's very hard on
them if they're treated inhospitably and
so you know one of the things we've
tried to do I travel with a fair number
of people now but everyone knows that
like rule number one is treat the
audience members even the ones that are
have some trouble and maybe even are
Troublesome it's like treat them like
their guests because they're guests and
you're bloody lucky that they're here so
don't get all high and mighty about it
because they put in their time and
effort to come here and they're looking
for something so that's part of that
gratitude that that and then it's fun
right that keeps it fun it's like you're
so privileged to be there talking to
them that's you got to have that in mind
what a privilege it is that what is
these people they're coming to listen to
what you're doing that's a good deal man
that's as good as it gets so you want to
have that firmly in the back of your
mind and the front too
yeah I'll try my best Jordan Peterson
ladies and gentlemen Jordan thank you so
much for today I'm looking forward to
the next time we get to catch up good to
talk to you Chris thank you very much
for tuning in if you enjoyed that
episode with Jordan you will love my
conversation with Douglas Murray which
is available right here go on tap it